donc l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au Gouvernement la première
d'entre elles va être posée par Madame
Sandrine Rousseau pour le groupe
écologiste
avant de débuter cette question au
gouvernement je souhaiterais que notre
assemblée rend hommage à l'Inspecteur
des Impôts tu es hier lors d'un contrôle
dans le Pas-de-Calais nous assurons ses
proches de notre soutien mais aussi de
notre clairvoyance sur le rôle tout à la
fois important et complexe que joue
actuellement les agents et agent du
service public qui se trouve en première
ligne de la crise sociale et de la
montée des tensions au sein de notre
société il est elles sont nombreuses à
faire part de la montée de la violence à
laquelle ils doivent faire face dans un
contexte de fragilisation permanente de
nos moyens et crédits nous demandons de
respecter une minute de silence
on demande une minute de silence madame
la Présidente
j'ai bien entendu madame Rousseau et
effectivement après cet acte absolument
tragique je pense qu'effectivement
l'Assemblée nationale peut s'associer à
la douleur de la famille et au respect
que nous devons à tous ces serviteurs de
l'État qui agissent au quotidien pour
notre pays
je vous remercie
ma question s'adresse désormais au
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald darmanian
monsieur le ministre
Gérald Darmanin
300 gendarmes policiers et militaire
français sont affectés à la sécurité de
la Coupe du Monde au Qatar ces
personnels français vous disaient
vont-ils me permettre aux personnes
lgbtqia plus de vivre sur place en
sécurité pourront-ils brandir un drapeau
aux couleurs LGBT pourront-ils et elle
s'embrasser dans la rue sous la
protection c'est de vous installer dans
le calme s'il vous plaît pourront-ils
demander l'intervention des forces de
l'ordre en cas de discrimination dans
l'accès aux chambres d'hôtel je rappelle
que l'affirmation d'une sexualité LGBT
et non seulement illégale au Qatar mais
peut conduire à de l'emprisonnement et
la peine de mort pour les personnes de
confusion de confession musulmanes selon
le gardien les autorités Cathary ne se
contenteraient pas d'arrêter volonté les
personnes LGBT elles auraient mis en
place un système sordide visant à visant
à les obliger à dénoncer d'autres
personnes LGBT pour échapper aux
tortures la FIFA quant à elle a interdit
explicitement le port du brassard Juan
love ce qui annonce rien de bon quand au
respect les droits des personnes la LGBT
phobie est un délit en France ma
question est donc simple la garantie des
droits des personnes LGBT fait-elle
partie des missions confiées aux forces
de l'ordre français
[Applaudissements]
aérien des stades de football du Qatar
ou des grandes équipes en de football
notamment notre équipe de France sur
place et en lien avec des industriels
français qui ont vendu les solutions
nous permettons ainsi de préparer la
Coupe du monde de rugby et les Jeux
Olympiques le troisième raison pour
laquelle les gendarmes et les policiers
français sont là c'est notamment la
formation qu'ils ont pu avoir sur les
motocyclistes qui accompagnaient les
délégations vous voyez enfin quatrième
sujet le GIGN qui est là pour intervenir
notamment pour protéger l'équipe de
France de football ou ses supporters en
cas d'attaque entre nos intérêts en
aucun cas les policiers gendarmes
français ne font du matcha de l'ordre au
Qatar en aucun cas ils sont en contact
avec la police qatari pour appliquer les
lois du Qatar ils sont là pour protéger
nos concitoyens et pour nous aider à
mieux organiser la Coupe du monde de
rugby et les Jeux Olympiques je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre madame
Rousseau mais en fait vous n'avez pas du
tout répondu à la question est-ce qu'il
les protégeront en cas de LGBT phobie
dans la rue cathari c'est ça la question
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Véronique Riotton
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à la fois à Madame la Ministre
de l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes de la diversité de l'égalité des
chances ainsi qu'à monsieur le ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse vendredi prochain nous serons
le 25 novembre Journée mondiale de
mobilisation pour l'éradication des
violences faites aux femmes le président
de la République a choisi de faire de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
la grande cause de son quinquennat et ce
pour la seconde fois consécutive la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes et le premier pilier de cette
grande cause depuis 2017 cette lutte a
fait l'objet d'un travail soutenu le
Grenelle des violences conjugales nous a
permis d'avancer concrètement avec 80%
de place d'hébergement en plus une
multiplication par 2 du budget du
ministère de l'Éducation et de l'égalité
femme homme et surtout des hommes et des
femmes policiers
mieux formés alors nous savons cependant
que les violences perpétrées sur les
femmes ne se cantonnent pas à l'intimité
des foyers c'est violences sont
présentes dans toutes les sphères de
notre société au niveau politique dans
la rue dans le sport au travail avec le
développement des outils numériques de
nouvelles formes de violence ce sont
développées je pense évidemment aux
violences faites aux femmes sur Internet
les cybers violences suite au
confinement l'association de protection
des mineurs sur Internet y enfance
comptabilise une hausse de 60% de ces
violences pour lutter efficacement
contre toutes ces formes de violence ce
combat nécessite l'engagement de tous
hommes comme femme de toutes les
générations nous devons évoquer
éduquer chacune chacun a une culture de
l'égalité et de la non-violence dès le
plus jeune âge à l'école afin de
prévenir toutes ces formes de violence
comme le disait demander là l'éducation
et l'arme la pluie puissante pour
changer le monde madame la ministre
pouvez-vous nous préciser les actions
que vous prévoyez en la matière je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à madame Isabelle Rome ministre délégué
chargé de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes de la diversité et de
l'égalité des chances
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente Véronique Riotton vous l'avez
rappelé depuis 2017 le gouvernement et
la majorité se sont mobilisés comme
jamais pour enrayer le fléau des
violences faites aux femmes à la suite
du Grenelle des violences conjugales
quatre lois ont été votées de manière
transpartisane pour mieux protéger les
victimes le nombre de téléphones graves
danger a été multiplié par 10 le nombre
d'ordonnances de protection par deux les
horaires du 39 19 étendues 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7 et le budget qui va
être alloué
à la FNSF qui gère justement le 39 17 39
19 va être de 5,9 millions d'euros grâce
à la majorité et au gouvernement soit
plus 400% en 5 ans le nombre de places
d'hébergement dédié aux victimes et à
leurs enfants a également augmenté plus
de 80%
pour mieux accompagner les victimes la
présence des intervenants sociaux dans
les commissariats et gendarmerie sera
renforcée ils seront 600 d'ici 2025
grâce à la loopy et ce sont aussi depuis
2017 160
000 policiers et gendarmes formés sans
et 30 centres de prise en charge ouvert
pour les auteurs afin d'éviter la
récidive
madame la Présidente vous l'avez dit les
violences faites aux femmes sont
structurelles c'est dès le plus jeune
âge qu'il faut construire une société
plus égalitaire plus respectueuse des
femmes la culture de l'égalité sera l'un
des axes forts du comité
interministériel à l'égalité femme homme
que la première ministre présidera dès
janvier prochain et que j'aurai à
piloter les violences faites aux femmes
sont indignes notre civilisation et
c'est sans relâche que le gouvernement
et la majorité mènent le combat contre
ce fléau et ma détermination est totale
je vous remercie madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Emmanuel
Fernandez pour le groupe la France
insoumise
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre du Travail c'est
le 21 novembre 1945 que votre illustre
prédécesseur Ambroise Croizat pris cette
fonction pour devenir le père de la
sécurité sociale cruelle ironique qui
veut que ce soit un autre 21 novembre
que votre nom monsieur du soft soit à
jamais associé à l'une des réformes les
plus antisociales de l'histoire oui
votre réforme de l'assurance chômage
c'est l'acte 2 de la guerre que mène
Emmanuel Macron au chômeur depuis 2017
après avoir réduit les droits de 1,15
millions de personnes vous annonciez
hier la baisse de 25% de la durée
d'indemnisation en cumulant les
économies de ces deux réformes le
président des riches aura repris d'une
main 6,6 milliards d'euros par an au
chômeur pour donner de l'autre main 1,7
millions d'euros par an au 100 Français
les plus riches par la suppression de
l'ISF et la flat tax vous faites les
poches au peuple mais vous gavez vos
amis pire votre injuste mécanisme de
modulation entraînera la double peine
dans les zones du pays où le chômage
continue d'augmenter dès lors que la
moyenne nationale sera tirée vers le bas
grâce aux régions où l'on embauche pour
vous les chômeurs sont des fainéants qui
profitent de leur douceoisiveté depuis
leur canapé assez de cette insupportable
mépris les demandeurs d'emploi subissent
leur situation dans leur quasi-totalité
votre volonté de leur tordre le bras
pour faire accepter n'importe quel
emploi précaire et voué à l'échec en
effet Monsieur le Ministre qu'est-ce que
vous ne comprenez pas dans la phrase il
n'y a qu'un emploi vacant pour 16
demandeurs savez-vous que plus de 40%
des chômeurs sont déjà dans la pauvreté
et enfin si malgré ces données
factuelles vous pensez toujours que le
chômage c'est trop rentable comparé au
fait de retourner bosser pourquoi ne pas
voter ce jeudi pour l'augmentation du
SMIC à 1600 euros
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du stop ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion
merci madame la Présidente et Messieurs
les Députés monsieur le député vous
l'avez dit hier j'ai présenté aux
partenaires sociaux les mécanismes de
modulation des règles d'indemnisation de
l'assurance chômage c'est l'application
d'un engagement que le Président de la
République a pris pendant la campagne et
que la majorité met en oeuvre
aujourd'hui au travers d'une loi qui a
été adoptée par le Parlement le Sénat et
l'assemblé la semaine dernière et qui va
donc entrer en application cette règle
elle s'appuie sur un principe simple
quand les choses vont bien les règles
d'indemnisation doivent être plus
incitatives et quand les choses vont mal
elles doivent être plus protectrices
vous avez essayé tracé un bilan qui
n'est pas la réalité du bilan du
gouvernement en matière d'emploi vous
avez qualifié le président de la
République comme vous savez le faire
c'est-à-dire avec beaucoup d'impolitesse
mais vous avez oublié un certain nombre
de choses
vous avez oublié que c'est cette
majorité donc ce président de la
République qui en 5 ans a permis à un
million 700 000 personnes de retrouver
le chemin de l'emploi que c'est cette
majorité qui a mis en place le plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
avec 15 milliards d'euros
dans le savoir et dans l'insertion c'est
cette majorité qui met en place le
contrat engagement jeune avec presse
300000 bénéficiaires des jeunes sans
emploi ni formation que l'on peut ainsi
raccompagner sur le chemin des
formations qualifiantes et sur le chemin
de l'emploi c'est aussi cette majorité
qui parce qu'elle a augmenté les crédits
consacrés à l'apprentissage permet à
notre pays d'avoir aujourd'hui plus de
800 000 apprentis avec une voie royale
pour la formation et l'insertion
professionnelle c'est enfin cette
majorité qui est depuis un an face aux
difficultés de recrutement des
entreprises a mis en place un plan de
réduction des tensions et figurez-vous
que ce plan de réduction des tensions a
permis de raccompagner vers l'emploi
280000 demandeurs d'emploi de longue
durée dont 156 000 de très longues
durées c'est aussi ce qui nous permet de
consacrer plus de moyens à
l'investissement dans les compétences et
dans l'insertion notre majorité monsieur
le député c'est celle du plein emploi
vous avez osé parler de mépris vis-à-vis
des chômeurs le seul mépris c'est le
vôtre c'est celui qui consiste à
souhaiter que la précarité reste parce
que je voulais déjà dire la précarité
c'est votre fond de commerce
je vous remercie
pour être 3 secondes
monsieur vous êtes lentilles Ambroise
croisable ou détruisez la solidarité
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à présent à Madame
Marietta carameli pour le gros
socialiste
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question avant de poser la question
monsieur le garde des sceaux ministre de
la justice je voulais quand même
rappeler que le 39 19 ça a été créé par
les socialistes le gouvernement donc
vient d'annoncer un plan pour la
protection des enfants et la lutte
contre les violences faites aux enfants
si l'intention est bonne elle ne doit
pas faire oublier justement l'actuel
réalité d'une justice sinistrée et je ne
parle pas ici que de justice pénale mais
aussi de justice civile il y a un pont
entier de la justice sinistrée ce sont
les affaires familiales au moment où
nous débattons il y a des manifestations
des protestations des magistrats et des
avocats qui pour reprendre le titre de
journaux sont au bord d'un burn out de
l'épuisement entre colère et amertume la
famille donc est certainement ce qui
compte le plus pour les Françaises et
les Français une séparation la gestion
de la garde des enfants un changement
dans la situation financière des époux
et des parents ce sont des choses
courantes que des effets difficiles au
tribunal judiciaire du Mans par exemple
le délai pour obtenir une audience et de
12 à 15 mois le quotidien donc ce sont
des séances à rallonge des familles
connaissant de nombreuses difficultés
pour divorcer ou obtenir la garde
d'enfants faute de délai raisonnable et
fragilisée par l'absence de décision des
magistrats fatigués et des avocats
démotivés devant expliquer pourquoi il
ne se passe rien il faut donc certes se
préoccuper de la violence mais aussi se
prémunir à la grève des situations qui
sont ordinaires j'ajoute que plan pénal
bon nombre d'affaires de violences
conjugales sont
oyées d'une année sur l'autre alors vous
me direz monsieur le ministre le budget
de justice et en augmentation et nous
avons recruté néanmoins il faut les
mesures d'urgence pertinentes et penser
avec les magistrats alors Monsieur le
Ministre ma question est simple que
comptez-vous faire d'exceptionnel
pour les familles et le droit à une
vraie justice que des magistrats évitent
le pire de pour leur santé et que les
avocats retrouvent leur efficacité je
vous remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Eric Dupond-Moretti ministre de la
Justice garde des sceaux
madame la présidente madame messieurs
les députés madame la députée vous dites
et je vous entends que la justice est
sinistrée
mais ces murs voyez-vous ont des
oreilles mais ils ont aussi une mémoire
il fut un temps pas si lointain vous
étiez au pouvoir où les augmentations de
budget c'était 1% et personne d'ailleurs
à l'époque ne disait rien alors vous
dites il ne se passe rien on va quand
même rappeler deux ou trois choses 44%
d'augmentation du budget depuis
l'élection du Président de la République
ça c'est nous madame plus 26%
d'augmentation du budget c'est nous
madame le plus grand plan d'embauche de
l'histoire de la justice 750 magistrats
850 greffiers 2000 contractuels c'est
nous madame la plus grande promotion de
l'École nationale de la magistrature il
nous faut des algeco car on ne peut pas
écarter les murs et puis 1000 euros
d'augmentation mensuelle net pour les
magistrats pas un magistrat ne
commencera à sa à moins de 3000 euros
pour l'urgence c'est dans quelques jours
les annonces des États généraux et vous
verrez les mesures qui sont prises en
matière civile en matière pénale en
matière économique et sociale nous nous
faisons pas que critiquer nous agissons
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Fabien dit
Filippo pour le groupe les républicains
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur
[Musique]
c'est le ministre qui avait du temps
Madame karamoly pas vous monsieur dit
Philippot
alors
[Applaudissements]
on remet le compteur à zéro pour
Monsieur dit Philippot
un nouveau merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur nous refusons de
voir la France devenir chaque jour un
peu plus l'eldorado de la clandestinité
l'accueil du bateau au Sean Viking et
ses 234 migrants finalement donné lieu
au fiasco judiciaire et sécuritaire
inévitable et annoncé à la fois sur
votre engagement monsieur le ministre
d'éloignement immédiat des déboutés du
droit d'asile la majorité s'est tante
évanouie dans la nature faute d'être
présentée à un juge dans les délais et
sur le contrôle des mineurs isolés dont
60% ont fugué le président Emmanuel
Macron qui livrait n'est pas un
revirement prêt déclaré pourtant en 2018
à propos de l'Aquarius que si la France
devenait le port d'accueil des bateaux
qui partent d'Afrique ce serait un
soutenable et que les bons sentiments
faciles feraient juste basculer le pays
vers les extrêmes il faut un message
limpide et plus ferme vous aviez entamé
à votre prise de fonction une tournée de
plusieurs pays pour négocier des laisser
passer consulaires et augmenter
l'exécution des expulsions dont 9 sur 10
reste aujourd'hui toujours l'être morte
mais l'octroi des visas réguliers l'aide
au développement doivent être désormais
conditionnés à la délivrance
systématique des laisser passer
consulaires pour éloigner les
clandestins il faut ensuite affirmer
sans aucune ambiguïté que les ONG et
leur bateau sont les complices
désorganisations criminelles et
mafieuses de passeurs qui provoque de la
misère et des drames humains en mer la
France doit soutenir la demande de
résolution des quatre pays
méditerranéens qui exigent que les pays
qui fournissent leur pavillon au bateau
privé des ONG en accueille alors les
migrants et assurent leur prise en
charge mais question sont donc directes
monsieur le ministre écoutez-vous enfin
les propositions de la droite
républicaine pour bâtir une politique
migratoire ferme et réaliste assurant la
sécurité de nos concitoyens
l'éloignement de ceux qui violent nos
lois et permettent l'intégration des
personnes qui mériteraient réellement
d'être accueillies ou alors
attendez-vous comme Gérard Collomb de
quitter le gouvernement pour dénoncer
l'hypocrisie laxiste du pouvoir et le
dévoiement des procédures migratoires
qui affaiblissent notre République je
vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente de Monsieur
député monsieur le député des Philippot
votre question est importante et touche
un petit migratoire de notre pays et
nous aurons bientôt l'occasion dans
cette même hémicycle le 6 décembre
prochain d'entendre les propositions
justement du groupe les républicains sur
la politique migratoire puisque un débat
est souhaité ici et au Sénat avant un
texte très important que j'ai eu
l'honneur de présenter avec Olivier du
soft déjà en préfiguration de nos
discussions qui sera ensuite transmis au
Conseil d'État après les débats
parlementaires après les consultations
politiques également et j'ai proposé à
votre groupe comme à tous les groupes de
venir discuter avec nous de ce texte
pour que nous puissions le construire
ensemble si nous trouvions des points
évidemment de compromis textes qui sera
discuté en janvier à partir de janvier
au Sénat puis sans doute par Sabrine ici
dans cette hémicycle on en tirera des
conclusions évidemment de ce que nous
avons vécu pour le CAD Viking et
notamment le droit qui n'est pas
forcément extrêmement adapté nous
l'avons tous compris à cette situation
mais également des moyens nous devons
mettre pour lutter contre l'immigration
clandestine tout en accompagnant et en
encourageant une immigration de travail
qui est souhaitée je le sais par
beaucoup de français nous voulons dire
aussi que l'aspect européen est très
important dès le mois de juin prochain à
Monsieur député un premier système
d'entrée sortie Schengen qui n'a jamais
existé auparavant aura lieu dans toute
l'Europe et c'est grâce à la présence
française de l'Union européenne et
l'action du Président de la République
et dès vendredi après-midi à la demande
de la France une réunion extraordinaire
des ministres de l'intérieur de l'Union
européenne prendra en compte la
proposition de la Commission européenne
rendue publique hier qui est en tout
point conforme à la position de la
France le droit de la mère doit être
respecté par tous les pays l'accueil des
étrangers doit être fait dans des bonnes
conditions sur le sol européen et les
pays de départ doivent être
responsabilisés notamment en
conditionnant comme vous l'avez dit des
aides au développement
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur des Philippot
oui en 2018 Gérard Collomb avait balayé
toutes nos propositions ils sont morts
aujourd'hui les droits c'est le dernier
rendez-vous de fermeté il faudra le
saisir je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Pradal
pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
garde des sceaux chers collègues ma
question à laquelle j'associe
Jean-Charles l'arseneur s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de la Justice au
sujet du mouvement des magistrats qui a
lieu aujourd'hui Monsieur le Ministre
les syndicats ont lancé un appel à la
grève un an après la publication la
tribune des 3000 qui vous alerter sur le
manque d'effectifs et de moyens
chroniques surbis par les magistrats
l'ensemble des professionnels de la
justice et les justiciables ces tribune
faisait suite aux malheureux suicide
d'une magistrate et nous saluons
également la mémoire de Madame la Juge
Marie trucher décédée tragiquement le 18
octobre dernier dans des circonstances
qui restent à déterminer je tiens à leur
rendre hommage
le quinquennat précédent a permis de
voter plusieurs réformes ambitieuses
pour cette majorité la sécurité et la
justice reste des priorités au service
de nos concitoyens la mission justice
dans le budget pour 2023 puis être
débattu et voté en commission et en
séance publique nous venons d'adopter la
loi d'orientation du ministère de
l'Intérieur et nous examinerons bientôt
si j'en crois les rumeurs une loi de
programmation de votre propre ministère
suite aux états généraux de la justice
qui sont en train de se conclure depuis
plusieurs années les crédits de votre
ministère sont en augmentation en accord
avec la politique souhaitée par le
Président de la République or certaines
expressions syndicales affirment que
depuis un an rien n'a été fait ainsi je
vous demande monsieur le ministre
d'exposer devant la représentation
nationale les mesures prises en faveur
d'un meilleur fonctionnement de la
justice depuis un an et également de
dire en quoi les crédits adoptés dans le
projet loi de finances 2023 permettant
d'améliorer les conditions de rendu de
la justice dans notre pays je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur Éric
Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux et
ministre de la Justice merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Pradal
d'abord je voudrais me joindre à
l'hommage
s'agissant évidemment du décès de Madame
Truchet j'ai une pensée particulière
pour elle pour sa famille bien sûr
je vais pas reprendre les chiffres que
j'ai donnés dans le cadre d'une
précédente question qui m'a été posée
par Madame karmonly mais je voudrais
dire que nous n'avons pas à rougir de ce
que nous avons fait et nous avons réparé
30 ans d'abandon humain politique et
budgétaire mais vous le savez parce que
vous êtes un député sérieux les choses
ne se font pas en un claquement de
doigts alors nous allons pour l'avenir
évidemment présenter une loi de
programmation c'est le député ça n'est
pas une rumeur madame la Première
ministre l'avait d'ores et déjà annoncé
c'est un grand plan d'embauche un
deuxième grand plan d'embauche 1500
magistrats 1500 greffiers 10000
personnels au total dans les
contractuels contractuelles dont je
rappelle qu'ils ont précédemment permis
de réduire les stocks notamment des
affaires civiles de plus de 25%. au-delà
de ça je présenterai quelques jours les
états généraux de la justice et de
grandes mesures de simplification en
matière civile aller vers l'amiable en
matière pénale des simplifications je
vous dis s'agissant du mouvement des
magistrats très franchement j'aurais
préféré que tous les syndicats de
magistrats viennent lors des
concertations que j'ai organisées dans
le cadre des États généraux certains
sont venus d'autres n'ont pas voulu et
j'ai affirmé à l'époque qu'une porte
ouverte qui n'était pas franchie n'était
pas une porte fermée ils ont choisi un
autre mode d'expression ça les regarde
je respecte cette liberté merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à présent à Madame
Mathilde de Paris pour le contrat
semblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur le 10 novembre l'exécutif a
pris la décision d'accueillir le bateau
aux séances Viking sur la base militaire
de Toulon
au journal de 20h vous avez déclaré
monsieur le ministre que les 234
migrants je cite ne pourront pas sortir
du centre administratif pourtant à peine
deux semaines plus tard la situation est
catastrophique la quasi-totalité de ces
migrants a été libérée sur les 44
mineurs prises en charge 26 ont fui sur
les 123 qui s'étaient vu refuser
l'entrée sur le territoire une centaine
à malgré tout été laissé libre de
quitter la zone d'attente sur décision
de justice au fond ce fiasco illustre
l'impuissance de votre gouvernement
impuissance à maîtriser les flux
migratoires impuissance face à
l'oppression des ONG d'extrême gauche
complice de passeurs impuissant sa
réformer la politique migratoire pour la
rendre plus dissuasive il est temps de
reprendre le contrôle je doute toutefois
de l'efficacité de la prochaine loi
immigration dont vous avez fait
référence tout à l'heure vous avez déjà
annoncé que profiterez de ce texte pour
créer une filière d'immigration pour les
métiers en tension concernant les propos
à l'instant de LR il y a les paroles et
les actes dans ma région Centre-Val de
Loire le groupe LR vote chaque année des
subventions à SOS Méditerranée
et oui
loin du laxisme de votre gouvernement le
rassemblement national à les solutions
et elles sont plébiscitées par les
Français
ma question est très simple
qu'attendez-vous pour donner la parole
au peuple en organisant un référendum
sur l'immigration merci
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
la présidente les députés même un député
permettez-moi de vous corriger c'est pas
l'exécutif qui accueille ce bateau c'est
notre humanité
et permettez-moi madame la députée de
vous dire que je suis très étonné de la
part de députés qui se disent nationaux
ou patriotes que vous préférez attaquer
le gouvernement plutôt que vos amis
italiens
et que finalement vous êtes très
internationaliste au lieu de voir dans
la décision madame mélony et de son
gouvernement le fait que vous n'avez
respecté au cœur du droit international
vous préférez attaquer les policiers
français Les Justiciers français qui ont
considéré qu'il fallait accueillir ces
personnes et notamment 44 enfants en
effet en effet madame vous n'êtes pas
toujours patriote lorsqu'il faut vous
alliez avec les ennemis de ceux qui
attaquent la France en ce moment
[Musique]
Madame nous avons respecté le droit
international nous avons accueilli ces
bateaux ensuite mise intérieur et ses
services respectent l'état droit et le
droit tout court et le juge des libertés
de la détention effectivement a permis
de sortir si j'ose dire ces personnes de
cette zone d'attente nous devons changer
le droit et c'est justement ce que nous
allons faire dans la loi immigration
nous verrons madame la députée quelle
sera votre position parce que si c'est
la même critique que lors du texte que
j'ai présenté sur la sécurité pendant
trois mois vous nous avez attaqué sur la
sécurité pour que dans deux heures en
catimini vous votiez notre texte et bah
alors je pense que ce sera beaucoup de
bruit pour rien
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame Paris
monsieur le ministre on peut tout à fait
preuve d'humanité mais de fermeté aussi
c'est ce que nous ne demandons pas autre
chose par ailleurs les Français ont le
droit d'être consulté sur un sujet aussi
grave c'est ce que nous vous demandons
tout simplement alors nos caricaturisez
pas s'il vous plaît le débat
je vous remercie
monsieur
il n'y a pas d'humanité qu'en 44 enfants
sont à bord et que nous ne vous
souhaitez pas les accueillir
il n'y a pas d'humanité madame lorsqu'on
a ce genre de position
la vérité madame
la vérité c'est que comme j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire vous ne souhaitez
pas entendre ce que fait le gouvernement
français à la fois de l'humanité
accueillir ce bateau fait respecter le
droit international et déjà c'est le cas
depuis ce matin reconduire des personnes
notamment au Mali un avion qui est déjà
parti madame c'est Monsieur Ménez
la parole est à Monsieur Loïc Prud'homme
pour le groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres l'inflation
dépasse à ce jour 6% mais sur les
denrées alimentaires c'est au minimum
12% et ce n'est pas fini il est bien
évident que tout le contenu de nos
assiettes n'arrive pas d'Ukraine c'est
donc bien que la spéculation c'est donc
bien la spéculation qui est responsable
de cette situation et ce sont toujours
les mêmes qui en tirent les bénéfices ou
plutôt devrais-je dire qui en tirent les
dividendes avec votre bénédiction dans
ce contexte ce sont plus de la moitié
des communes qui est augmenté les tarifs
des cantines scolaires de 5 à 10%.
d'autres prennent sur leur ressources
propres pour maintenir des tarifs
accessibles aux familles les
collectivités sont prises entre le
marteau et l'enclume d'un côté
l'augmentation inédite des prix de
l'alimentation en plus de celui de
l'énergie de l'autre des familles
impactées durement par l'inflation avec
le refus de votre gouvernement
d'augmenter les salaires
cette réalité ce quotidien votre
gouvernement le regarde les bras
ballants sans prendre une seule mesure
de soutien mais en continuant à
pressurer les finances des communes
cette inaction coupable provoque des
dégâts en cascade du côté des
gestionnaires baisse de la part des
produits locaux bio et de qualité baisse
des quantités servies arbitrage entre
fromage et dessert du côté des familles
retrait des enfants de la cantine pour
les plus fragiles et de fait renoncement
à ce qui est souvent le seul repas
équilibré de la journée à quand la
cantine scolaire gratuite
alors que les fils s'allongent devant
l'aide alimentaire cette crise dans les
cantines scolaires est moins visibles
allez-vous continuer à faire comme si
elle n'existait pas ou allez-vous enfin
débloquer en urgence 600 millions
d'euros soit à peine 1% des dividendes
du CAC 40 vers les collectivités locales
pour que nos enfants puissent manger
correctement ou bien allez-vous encore
dire aux Français à leurs enfants qui
doivent se serrer la ceinture mais cette
fois au sens propre quand d'autres sont
obèses de leur super profit
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Caroline cailleux ministre délégué
chargé des collectivités territoriales
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Prud'homme je tiens à l'affirmer devant
vous cet après-midi oui le gouvernement
soutient les collectivités territoriales
les soutiens face au prix de l'énergie
face à l'inflation face aux nombreux
défis qui les attendent le PLF adopté
par l'Assemblée nationale est un PLF en
faveur des collectivités
concernant les cantines scolaires
que vous évoquez je tiens d'abord à vous
rappeler que c'est une compétence des
communes et qu'elle les gère et qu'elles
ont le choix du mode de gestion
[Musique]
toutefois toutefois je voudrais vous
dire que le gouvernement a mis en place
des dispositifs ciblés dès le PLFR pour
les communes fragiles pour les aider
pour les cantiques scolaires pour
l'alimentation et pour l'inflation nous
avons pris en compte nous avons pris en
compte ces coûts supplémentaires liés à
ses dépenses et les services locaux de
restauration verront leurs dépenses
énergétique soutenues à travers
différents dispositifs à l'intention des
collectivités qu'il s'agisse du bouclier
tarifaire ou qu'il s'agisse de
l'amortisseur électrique et puis nous
poursuivrons avec mon collègue papendaye
nos actions en faveur des cantines les
cantines à 1 euro les petits déjeuners
gratuits à l'école primaire la Bourse et
les fonds sociaux voilà ce que nous
faisons voilà ce que le gouvernement
fait pour les collectivités
je vous remercie madame la ministre
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Michel lauzana
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur François Brown
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
monsieur le ministre papa pourquoi tu te
laisses se pousser la moustache voici la
question d'un jeune citoyen à son papa
Charles lors d'une rencontre dans ma
circonscription de Lot-et-Garonne depuis
le mois de novembre Charles a également
des dizaines de milliers de Français se
laissent pousser la moustache dans le
cadre du mouvement Movember qui prend de
l'ampleur en particulier dans le milieu
du rugby ce mois est dédié à la
sensibilisation de l'opinion publique au
cancer masculin et ainsi briser les
tabous encore trop nombreux chez les
hommes
un peu de silence s'il vous plaît deux
hommes meurent chaque jour d'un cancer
masculin alors qu'il représente 52% des
cancers diagnostiqués les hommes sont
beaucoup moins nombreux que les femmes à
participer aux campagnes de dépistage
les raisons sont simples multiples la
peur d'être atteint dans sa virilité la
réticence aux examens ou encore le
sentiment de gêne voire de honte
monsieur le ministre je salue votre
engagement en faveur de la prévention en
particulier dans le PLFSS pour 2023
ainsi que la place importante de
celle-ci dans la stratégie décennale je
salue également la mobilisation
exemplaire des associations et bénévoles
engagés sur l'ensemble du territoire à
travers des manifestations locales et
des campagnes de prévention pour
informer les hommes sur le dépistage
cependant les tabous ne sont pas encore
brisés dans l'opinion publique nous
devons poursuivre et intensifier nos
actions car la diagnostiquer tôt les
cancers masculins ce soignent dans la
très grande majorité des cas ainsi
Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous nous
exposer votre stratégie pour poursuivre
le travail de sensibilisation afin de
mettre un terme au tabou des hommes face
au conserves je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
François Braun ministre de la Santé de
la prévention
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Lausana je vous remercie de votre
question qui me permet d'aborder un
sujet qui vous le savez mais
particulièrement cher qui est celui de
la prévention
la prévention reste quand même le
meilleur moyen d'améliorer la santé de
nos concitoyens et c'est en plus un
excellent moyen pour faire des économies
de la santé puisqu'on peut considérer
que 1 euro mais aujourd'hui dans la
prévention ce sera 2 euros économiser
demain
40% des cancers que nous diagnostiquons
chaque année sont liés à notre mode de
vie ils sont donc évitables c'est un
enjeu majeur pour notre société
aujourd'hui et demain alors je salue moi
aussi le mouvement Movember sur le
dépistage du cancer de la prostate je
tiens aussi à saluer et à rappeler à
cette assemblée que
le mois de novembre est également le
mois sans tabac et qu'il conviendrait là
aussi de faire un effort sur ce facteur
de risque qui entraîne des cancers
multiples et pas que le cancer du poumon
alors la prévention des cancers
masculins vous avez raison elle est
insuffisamment développée
pourtant les outils existent dépistage à
partir de 50 ans du cancer colorectal 55
ans du cancer de la prostate et
concernant le cancer colorectal par
exemple il n'y a que un tiers de la
population cible qui est aujourd'hui
concernée alors le gouvernement avance
pour faire ces notre société une société
de prévention les rendez-vous prévention
aux âges clés de la vie en sont une part
importante et s'intéresseront et
s'intéresse bien entendu à l'ensemble
des cancers les cancers masculins en
grande partie également
concernant ces rendez-vous de prévention
deux enjeux majeurs aller chercher les
personnes les plus loin du soin et
proposer également des parcours de
prévention nous ont l'occasion d'en
parler la prévention c'est prendre soin
de soi pour autant nous sommes tous
concernés pour les uns et les autres et
je suis confiant nous allons réussir à
transformer notre société vers une
société de prévention je vous remercie
merci
[Applaudissements]
Goulet pour le groupe rassemblement
national
[Applaudissements]
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique
12% d'inflation pour l'alimentation 17%
pour les produits frais voilà la réalité
qu'affrontent les familles françaises
alors que les salaires eux peinent à
augmenter de 4%. ces chiffres alarmants
cachent de très grandes disparités les
huiles alimentaires ont augmenté de 60%,
les légumes de 33%, les pâtes le lait
les œufs le beurre connaissent des os de
15 à 20% ce matin le dirigeant d'une
enseigne de grandes distribution
indiquée qu'il refusait de mettre en
rayon des produits de base devenus si
chers que la plupart des Français ne
pouvaient les acheter comment accepter
une situation indigne d'une grande
puissance agricole comme la France
désormais incapable d'assurer
l'alimentation saine et abordable à ses
habitants
Marine Le Pen a alerté dès septembre
2021 avant la guerre en Ukraine sur la
gravité de l'inflation alimentaire mais
aussi sur sa durée dans le temps pendant
des mois vous avez annoncé que la France
avait passé le pic d'inflation pour
justifier votre passivité au dernier
élections vous avez promis un chèque
alimentation que vous avez finalement
enterré ma question est donc simple
quand allez-vous appliquer la seule
mesure concrète pour soulager les
Français la baisse à 0% de la TVA sur un
panier de produits d'alimentation et
d'hygiène avec un strict contrôle de la
répercussion sur la baisse des prix
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés avant de répondre
à un député du rassemblement national je
voudrais m'associer à l'hommage qui
était rendu à l'agent de la Direction
générale des finances publiques qui
étaient assassiné à côté d'Arras il y a
quelques heures
dire à tous les agents de la DGFiP les
96.000 agents la direction générale des
finances publiques aux 4000 agents
vérificateurs qui sont au contact direct
du terrain tout mon soutien toute ma
reconnaissance
et toute l'amitié de la République et de
la nation française que vous représentez
ici
merci à toutes et à tous
madame la députée bien entendu que
l'inflation des produits alimentaires
pèse très durement sur tous nos
compatriotes
nous avons anticipé l'augmentation des
prix ou pariez des propositions qui ont
été faites par la présidente Le Pen il y
a quelques mois je rappelle que cette
majorité la seule en Europe en octobre
2021 a pris la décision de protéger tous
nos compatriotes contre l'explosion des
prix du gaz et l'explosion des prix de
l'électricité je rappelle que la France
la première et la seule en Europe a
engagé 110 milliards d'euros de dépenses
pour protéger notre compatriote contre
l'augmentation des prix là vous me direz
c'est pas les prix alimentaires mais nos
compatriotes ont un seul budget et il
est répartissent leurs dépenses entre le
logement l'alimentation le déplacement
l'électricité l'énergie et c'est grâce à
cette protection que la France madame la
députée garde le taux d'inflation le
plus faible de la zone euro et ça c'est
un chiffre c'est un fait nous avons
protégé mieux et plus tôt que les autres
nations européennes
nous continuerons nous continuerons à le
faire en ciblant la protection sur ceux
qui sont les plus fragiles en aidant les
entreprises j'aurais l'occasion d'en
reparler qui font elles aussi fassent à
l'explosion de leur facture nous n'avons
jamais laissé tomber personne pendant
les périodes de crise ni pendant le
covid ni pendant les autres crises nous
serons au côté de nos compatriotes
pendant cette crise de l'inflation et
c'est explosion des prix de l'énergie
merci Monsieur le Ministre madame boulet
monsieur le ministre vous savez très
bien que les Français sont obligés de
faire des choix et les sacrifices sur le
panier le panier d'aliment
d'alimentation et que par ailleurs vos
mesures ne sont pas pérennes alors que
vous savez très bien que la crise est
appelée a duré et que ça ne satisfa pas
ça nous satisfait pas un grand nombre de
Français
je vous remercier la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Marc Tellier pour le
groupe GDR
madame la Présidente Mesdames messieurs
les ministres chers collègues l'effet
sont implacables en France la peau la
pauvreté gagne du terrain plus de 10
millions de Français vivent aujourd'hui
sous le seuil de pauvreté les
Restaurants du Coeur constatent une
hausse de 12% de l'aide alimentaire les
rapports du Secours Catholique et du
Secours populaire doivent nous alerter
notre jeunesse est très impacté les
18-25 ans représentent près de 24% des
travailleurs pauvres quant au privé
d'emploi moins de sur deux est indemnisé
les fautifs ce ne sont pas la pandémie
ou l'inflation qui ne font qu'aggraver
la situation les fautifs c'est vous
c'est vous les responsables de la
destructuration du Code du travail de
l'assurance chômage véritable trappe à
emploi précaire et pendant que les
ménages peinent à boucler les fins de
mois à l'ouverture des congrès du
Congrès des mers les élus locaux sont
nous alertes sur cette situation sociale
dramatique qui met en première ligne nos
services publics et nos centres communal
d'action sociale
l'explosion des dépenses liées à
l'énergie augmente considérablement et
impact les budgets de nos collectivités
quels services devront-ils supprimer
demain
chez moi dans le Pas-de-Calais comme
ailleurs en France trop de communes sont
laissés pour compte
dans le cadre du filet de sécurité
comment peut-on expliquer que seul 2100
communes ont reçu un acompte comment
peut-on expliquer que dans ma région des
Hauts de France l'une l'un des
territoires les plus pauvres de France
seulement 8 communes dans le Nord l'ont
reçu 0 dans le Pas-de-Calais 0 dans la
Somme 0 dans l'aine pouvez-vous nous
assurer
qu'aucune commune ne passera au travers
du filet de sécurité
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
de territoire madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Tellier vous évoquez
les remontées à l'issue du vote du filet
de sécurité de 430 millions d'euros qui
a fait l'objet d'aller-retour entre la
représentation nationale ici à
l'Assemblée au Sénat et avec le
gouvernement pour être retenu dans le
cadre du PFR définitif
et effectivement la date du milieu du
mois de novembre correspond au moment où
les demandes d'acompte de la part des
collectivités pouvaient être formulés
avec dans ce filet une somme sur
laquelle il y a eu un accord politique
je le redis entre majorité opposition
mais des critères notamment sur la
baisse de la capacité d'autofinancement
brut calée sur 25% qui avait conduit à
ce qu'une estimation à 22 000 communes
soit évoquée dans l'hémicycle avec des
premières remontées qui aujourd'hui nous
donnent le sentiment que ce seuil est
trop haut pour déclencher le financement
des sommes dont nous parlons à la minute
où je suis en train de parler avec vous
la direction générale des collectivités
locales les allers-retours entre le
ministère de la cohésion des territoires
et les remontées que nous avons des
différents territoires sont en train de
reprendre ces éléments l'engagement du
gouvernement exprimait avec beaucoup de
force par le ministre de l'économie et
des finances au moment de la fin de ce
PLF c'était bien cette accompagnement
auteur de 430 millions d'euros si
l'assouplissement des critères et le
moyen de tenir le niveau de financement
sur lequel nous sommes mis d'accord
c'est une perspective à laquelle nous
souscrivons dans la même dans le même
principe
l'amendement qui a été déposé et repris
dans le cadre de la première partie du
budget sur le soutien en collectivités
locales déposée par la députéisme manier
fait lui aussi l'objet d'un examen pour
qu'on vérifie si ce premier critère sur
la perte d'autofinancement n'a pas été
trop restrictif sur la capacité à
pouvoir aider les collectivités donc
pour vous dire les choses l'engagement
du gouvernement il est bien
d'accompagner les collectivités face à
la flambée des prix à la hauteur des 430
millions et d'ajuster le filet à la
réalité de la somme sur laquelle nous
sommes mis d'accord je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Anne Bergen pour
le groupe démocrate
mesdames le présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Madame Charlotte
CODEL secrétaire d'État auprès de la
première ministre chargé de l'enfant au
cours des derniers jours nous
institutions ont mis les enfants et
leurs paroles à l'honneur que ce soit
lors d'un débat inversé organisé par la
présidentielle brune Pivet avec l'UNICEF
ou avec la tenue d'un conseil des
ministres des enfants présidé par madame
la Première ministre ces événements sont
la preuve de la volonté du gouvernement
d'obtenir de réelles avancées sur la
protection de l'enfance la création
d'une délégation parlementaire au droit
de l'enfant le 13 septembre dernier
présidé par notre collègue Perrine
Goulet démontre cette volonté d'être à
l'écoute de la Parole de la jeunesse
cependant si des progrès significatifs
ont été réalisés ces dernières années
beaucoup restent à faire un rapport de
l'Unicef paru dimanche dernier à
l'occasion de la Journée internationale
des droits de l'enfant fait état d'une
situation à l'armante un enfant meurt
tous les 5 jours suite à des violences
très majoritaires ment intrafamilial oui
vous avez bien entendu un enfant meurt
tous les 5 jours en France nous ne
pouvons accepter une France ou une
partie de nos enfants sont en danger et
ne sont pas protégés et la notion de
progrès n'aura aucun sens tant que tous
les moyens ne seront pas engagés pour
faire cesser ces situations madame la
ministre vous avez su identifier ces
difficultés en créant un comité
interministériel de l'enfance voici ma
question pourriez-vous nous faire un
retour des échanges suite à la réunion
de ce comité qui a eu lieu hier et nous
préciser quelle mesure vous envisagez
afin de lutter contre les violences
faites aux enfants
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
la secrétaire des tâches chargée de
l'enfance madame la présidente madame la
députée bergonze Mesdames et Messieurs
les parlementaires violence sur les
enfants sans tes mentale danger sur le
numérique oui un certain nombre de
signaux restent extrêmement alarmants
l'enfant sait donc une priorité du
quinquennat le président l'a affirmé le
Parlement et le gouvernement sont
pleinement mobilisés vous l'avez rappelé
c'est dans cet objectif que la première
ministre a réuni hier le premier comité
interministériel de l'enfance au
lendemain de la journée internationale
des droits de l'enfant
avec l'ensemble des ministres concernés
la première ministre a déterminé 5
chantiers prioritaires et une
quarantaine de mesures dont il
m'appartiendra d'assurer le suivi et la
coordination le premier chantier c'est
celui de la lutte contre les violences
faites aux enfants et vous l'avez
rappelé les chiffres sont extrêmement
impressionnants le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin a annoncé la
création d'un office de police
judiciaire dédié aux audiences faites
aux enfants
le garde des sceau Eric Dupont-Moretti
portera une circulaire de politique
pénale dédiée à ce sujet qui sera
diffusé auprès des parquets le second
chantier c'est celui de la santé de la
santé physique et mentale de nos enfants
et on sait comme elle est atteinte à la
sortie de la crise sanitaire le ministre
François Brown a annoncé des Assises de
la santé des enfants au printemps
prochain troisième priorité le numérique
partout où sont nos enfants nous devons
les protéger notamment sur Internet le
président de la République l'a rappelé
au Forum de la de Paris sur la paix et a
lancé un laboratoire sur la protection
des enfants sur le numérique avec
Jean-Noël Barrault nous conduirons une
campagne de sensibilisation auprès des
parents et nous rendrons effectifs la
loi sudor sur le contrôle parental dans
les jours qui viennent le ministre
d'éducation papendent généralisera le
passeport pix bref notre action aux
côtés des départements pour les publics
les plus fragiles continuera à être
effective je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame
Estelle Youssoupha pour le groupe liote
merci madame la Présidente les questions
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
depuis quelques jours nos compatriotes
découvrent avec epharma la violence qui
est notre quotidien à Mayotte depuis
plusieurs années en ce moment même
kawinny est en proie aux flammes et les
forces de leurs dons je salue le courage
affronte les émeutiers à Mayotte chaque
jour nos enfants vont à l'école la peur
au ventre parce que les établissements
scolaires sont attaqués les entreprises
sont incendiées les automobilistes sont
agressés par des hordes de jeunes démons
qui se déplacent par centaines des
barbares en culotte courte de 12 à 13
ans armés de machettes de barres de fer
de cailloux qui tue qui agresse qui
détruisent et sème le chaos des mineurs
des jeunes adultes la plupart étrangers
en situation irrégulière que nous
plantes terroriste parce qu'ils mettent
notre île à feu et à sang et sème la
terreur pour nous faire fuir alors
depuis plusieurs mois en caillasse les
bus scolaires et on attaque les collèges
et les lycées maintenant on y entre à la
machette quand dites-vous trop c'est
trop en début d'année des morceaux de
corps humain ont été déposés en évidence
sur la route pour terroriser la
population à Mayotte maintenant deux
personnes ont été torturées et amputés à
la machette en quelques jours seulement
quel acte de barbarie supplémentaire
faut-il pour que la République réagisse
quel traumatisme de plus devons-nous
subir pour que la nation exprime sa
solidarité avec Mayotte quel avenir pour
Mayotte si nos enfants sont assassinés
quand ils vont à l'école
madame la Première ministre la
population veut se rendre justice
elle-même et c'est de la légitime
défense quand elle est ainsi attaquée et
abandonnée à elle-même le ministère de
l'Intérieur vient d'envoyer des renforts
et me nous en remercions mais quand
allez-vous ordonner le déploiement de la
Marine nationale pour protéger notre
frontière et donner des moyens à la
justice pour opérer dans notre
département madame la Première ministre
qu'entendez-vous faire pour éviter la
guerre civile à Mayotte
la parole
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs députés madame la député
Estelle Youssoupha nous connaissons
notre engagement ainsi que celui de
monstres et mardi ne pour l'île de
Mayotte vous répétez sans cesse et vous
avez bien raison que les Mahorais qui
ont choisi de rester dans la République
et nous sommes fiers et heureux que vous
soyez pleinement dans la République ont
besoin de la protection de l'État les
augmentations des moyens continue du
ministère de l'Intérieur se sont encore
concrétisés avec ce week-end l'envoi du
raid vous l'avez souligné merci de
l'avoir fait pour justement rétablir la
paix publique à Mayotte et notamment à
Mamoudzou puisque ces derniers temps
effectivement des actes absolument
inacceptables ont été commis nous avons
plusieurs évidemment pistes d'évolution
j'en suis entretenu avec vous lorsque je
suis venu à Mayotte et le président de
la République lui-même préside au moyen
qu'il va dessiner au territoire romain
Auray d'abord des renforcements très
importants des mains de la justice le
garde des soins est l'occasion d'évoquer
des centres éducatifs fermés à Mayotte
mais aussi en nombre de magistrats et en
nombre de décisions que pour en prendre
pour répondre au rendez-vous des
interpellations qui sont nombreuses je
le répète pour mémoire en 2021 2
interpelle d'interpellation d'étrangers
régulières
23724 reconduite à la frontière 325
opérations évidemment de police ces
trois derniers mois et ce plan
judiciaire 324 passeurs dont quatre
filières qui avaient une réaction
criminelle à leur tête et notamment
domicile et d'actes de barbarie qui ont
été interpellés il faut les présenter à
la justice et ses moyens je le sais le
garder ça y réfléchis sous l'autorité du
Président de la République sur le côté
militaire vous avez parfaitement raison
nous avons entendu votre demande et avec
le ministre des Armées nous travaillons
d'ailleurs en partie ce soir à lors de
l'élaboration d'un lot de programmation
militaire qui a chapitre particulier
puisse se tenir pour la Guyane et pour
Mayotte pour renforcer les moyens
militaires il appartiendra ministre des
Armées évidemment d'annoncer ses moyens
mais je crois qu'ils vont dans le sens
de vos demandes et puis troisième sujet
pour nous c'est une opération vous le
savez sur lequel travaille l'État
allemand du président de la République
de mettre fin au bon gars sur une partie
en tout cas du territoire Mahoré une
opération de grande envergure nous
enverrons beaucoup de gendarmerie de
gendarmes mobiles
les deux moyens de l'État pour
effectivement inverser la courbe de la
violence et permettre aux petits mahory
d'aller normalement en classe comme au
baoué de vivre normalement
[Musique]
est un monsieur Jocelyn de ciné pour le
groupe rassemblement national
présidente merci ma question s'adresse
au ministre de l'Éducation monsieur
papendaye les investigations de la
sous-direction antiterroriste révélez
récemment indique clairement que Samuel
Paty se sentait traqué se trouvait dans
un état de grande anxiété ces recherches
sur Google le montrent menace à l'ordre
public code pénal et même à son propre
nom le jour de son assassinat il demande
à un de ses collègues de leur
accompagner chez lui il dissimulait son
visage sous une capuche dès sa sortie de
l'établissement et dans son sac à dos on
a retrouvé un marteau tous ces signes
prouvent s'il le fallait l'effroyables
et profonde solitude qu'il ressentait
face à une menace sérieuse et
potentiellement mortelle
cela pose question alors même que le
personnel d'accueil du collège témoigne
des appels d'alerte qu'il a reçu du
Maroc des États-Unis du Canada et du
monde entier malgré l'ampleur de la
politique et son caractère alarmant
c'est Samuel Paty qui doit se justifier
face à ses collègues en revendiquant son
athéisme pour répondre à un procès en
islamophobie intenté par deux d'entre
eux dans cette histoire tragique le
grand absent c'est l'état comment un
enseignant peut-il se trouver menacé de
mort en danger manifeste dans son propre
établissement et en dehors sans que
l'État ne lui fournisse l'attention et
la protection dont il a besoin monsieur
Blanquer indiquait que la doctrine de
l'éducation nationale n'était plus de
mettre le les problèmes sous le tapis
tous les signalements remontent que
pouvez-vous nous dire de plus sur le
nombre de signalements reçus et sur les
mesures prises en conséquence quelles
sont les mesures de protection concrètes
mises en place
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur pape and dye ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs
les Députés monsieur le député de Signy
la commémoration de l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty le 16 octobre dernier a été
l'occasion de réaffirmer les valeurs de
la République qui sont des valeurs de
léaïcité et la laïcité ça n'est pas
seulement une contrainte c'est la
garantie de l'émancipation par le savoir
par la transmission de savoir dans les
établissements scolaires à cette
occasion et dans la foulée des vacances
d'automne j'ai eu l'occasion de préciser
un certain nombre de mesures concernant
la protection des enseignants tout
d'abord la protection fonctionnelle qui
est accordée par l'administration aux
enseignants qui le demandent par
ailleurs le dépôt systématique de
plainte en lien avec les préfectures les
dépôts sont faits à la fois par les
enseignants quand ils sont menacés mais
également par les chefs d'établissement
nous le faisons systématiquement avec
l'appui de l'administration centrale
enfin nous
enjoignons également les personnels de
l'Éducation nationale a fait remonter
toute menace ou toute tentative
d'intimidation sur les réseaux sociaux
également dans les enceintes scolaires
de manière à mesurer précisément ces
phénomènes et à pouvoir agir nous
protégeons nous surveillons les
phénomènes que vous indiquez de manière
à ce que les menaces qui puissent porter
sur les enseignants ne se reproduisent
pas
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur destiny
dans ma circonscription comme dans
l'ensemble du territoire de nombreux
enseignants s'autocensure face à des
menaces islamiques croissantes quand
allez-vous sérieusement protéger les
professeurs pour qu'ils puissent
enseigner sereinement les valeurs de la
République
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur taux de
Cazenave pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à la ministre
déléguée aux collectivités territoriales
5 milliards en cinq ans c'est le budget
qui était loué au programme Action cœur
de ville lors de la dernière mandature
et qui a bénéficié à 234 villes de
taille moyenne sur tout le territoire ce
programme répondait à un objectif clair
réhabiliter les centres-villes pour
soutenir l'activité économique et
culturelle de ces territoires actions
coeur de ville a été largement
plébiscitée par les élus locaux de tout
bord qui se sont pleinement engagés à
porter des projets ambitieux au service
de leur ville grâce au volontarisme de
l'État des collectivités territoriales
de la banque des territoires d'Action
Logement de l'Agence nationale pour la
mission de l'habitat 6500 actions ont
été d'engagées dans tous les domaines
79000 logements rénovés mille cellules
commerciales restructurées et
requalifier de nombreuses opérations
d'aménagement et de réhabilitation du
patrimoine engagée
aujourd'hui les premiers résultats sont
là confirmant le bien-fondé du programme
et de cette méthode originale la
progression de la vacances commerciale a
été stoppée et commence à refluer les
transactions immobilières sont
redevenues dynamiques la fréquentation
des centres-villes et repartie à la
hausse les élus de Séville ont exprimé
leurs attentes très fortes pour pouvoir
continuer ce chantier qui pour tenir
toutes ses promesses doit s'inscrire
dans la durée madame la ministre vous
avez annoncé dimanche un nouveau
programme doté de 5 milliards d'euros
pour poursuivre action coeur de ville
pouvez-vous nous dire comment et dans
quel délai ce nouveau programme sera
mise en oeuvre et comment il intègrera
l'indispensable accélération des
investissements pour la transition
écologique de nos territoires je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Caroline cailleux ministre
délégué chargé des collectivités
territoriales
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Thomas Cazenave alors que ce s'ouvre
cette semaine le Congrès des mers merci
d'attirer l'attention sur ce programme
Action corps du ville qui a été un
formidable accélérateur pour les projets
des 234 villes partenaires et je dirais
un parfait exemple de la nouvelle
méthode poursuivie par le gouvernement
dès le premier quinquennat et que nous
allons poursuivre comme vous l'avez
souligné depuis son lancement les villes
moyennes ont bénéficié grâce à l'État et
à nos partenaires la banque des
territoires actions logements Elana de
formidable outil pour revitaliser leur
centre-ville et les résultats que vous
mentionnez monsieur le député montre que
la promesse politique a été tenue sur la
deuxième phase du programme que j'ai
annoncé il y a quelques jours j'ai
précisé les grand axes qui devrait
bénéficier d'abord d'au moins 5
milliards sur les quatre années qui qui
viennent et ce programme à la différence
du premier qui visait la revitalisation
des centres-villes nous avons fait le
choix de faire de la transition
écologique et transition énergétique le
véritable conducteur d'actions de ville
2 c'est un objectif crucial au moment où
nos communes traversent un défi
structurel pour
que représente le réchauffement
climatique et donc ce sera par exemple
l'intensification de la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments des bâtiments
publics des écoles et qu'ils soient
aussi des logements résidentiels
tertiaires ou public des mesures fortes
aussi pour le traitement des friches qui
va continuer pour ces villes ou la
requalification des entrées de ville
pour favoriser la nature en ville et
puis un accompagnement renforcé des
maires pour gérer l'énergie de leur
commune merci madame la Présidente
la parole est à Monsieur Bastien Lachaud
pour le couple la France insoumise merci
présidente monsieur le ministre Alima
habite la cité Gabriel Péri à
Aubervilliers elle a froid pendant
presque tout l'hiver dernier si on
appartenant n'a pas été chauffé l'hiver
est à nouveau là elle a de nouveau froid
près de 20% des logements de l'office
HLM d'Aubervilliers ne sont pas chauffés
l'histoire d'alima c'est celle de
millions de locataires du parc social
dans notre pays si mal en point mal en
point à cause de votre politique
désastreuse entre 2018 et 2022 vous avez
privé les organismes HLM de 6 milliards
d'euros le résultat est accablant chute
des nouvelles constructions immeubles
mal entretenu ascenseur et chaudière qui
ne marche pas vous avez clochardisez le
logement social
aujourd'hui en pleine crise de l'énergie
vous abandonnez les bailleurs sociaux la
moitié d'entre eux vont devoir
renégocier leur contrat d'énergie en
2023 avec des tarifs parfois multipliés
par 3 ou 4 et votre bouclier tarifaire
est une passoire qui ne coulent les
couvre pas à 100%. l'Union Sociale de
l'habitat qui regroupe les bailleurs
sociaux ne cessent de tirer la sonnette
d'alarme les hausses des tarifs se
répercutent sur les locataires le
thermomètre décend mais les prix eux
montent ceux des loyers jusqu'à 3,5% en
janvier se décharge qui vont exploser du
fait de la crise énergétique comment
faire face quand on est à quelques euros
près chaque mois
dans le logement social 35% des
habitants vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté la majorité gagne seulement le
SMIC vont-ils devoir choisir entre se
loger se chauffer et manger alors
qu'attendez-vous qu'attendez-vous pour
taxer les super profits des fournisseurs
pour bloquer les prix de l'énergie pour
protéger et aider réellement les
bailleurs sociaux pour que nos
concitoyens les plus modestes comme
Halima n'est pas un grelotter de froid
chez eux cet hiver
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier Klein
ministre délégué chargé de la ville et
du Logement madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les les députés
monsieur le député Lachaux d'abord si
vous connaissez un organisme de logement
social en Seine-Saint-Denis qui n'est
pas capable de chauffer c'est le
locataire je m'étonne que vous m'en
parliez que seulement je pense qu'on
aurait pu en parler très largement mon
adresse est largement ouverte et je peux
vous assurer qu'aucune aucun bailleur
social en Seine-Saint-Denis ne chauffe
pas ses locataires ou non mais
évidemment ensuite pour ce qui est des
boucliers vous le savez vous le savez le
gouvernement agit agit pour des
boucliers agit pour des boucliers
individuels et des boucliers collectifs
les boucliers collectifs au gaz
s'appliquent depuis avril 2022 et ôté
prolongé jusqu'à la fin de cette année
seront prolongés encore et on y
travaille en 2023 ils sont équivalents à
ceux des boucliers individuels et il
marche aussi pour les réseaux de
chauffage urbain oui il y avait un souci
sur le chauffage collectif électrique ce
souci nous sommes en train de le régler
la première ministre l'a annoncé et nous
ferons paraître très rapidement les
décrets permettant à toutes les
copropriétés ainsi qu'aux parties
communes de d'être soumises au même
bouclier bien évidemment et nous y
travaillons tous les jours avec l'Union
Sociale de l'habitat avec les syndics
pour régler l'ensemble de ces
difficultés il reste encore un certain
nombre de difficultés à régler mais je
peux vous assurer que nous y travaillons
d'arrache-pied merci je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre monsieur Lachaud
oui monsieur le ministre vous me dites
que je ne vous en parle que maintenant
mais vous n'avez même pas encore publié
les décrets donc vous n'avez rien
planifié aujourd'hui les gens ont froid
et c'est votre politique qui en est la
cause je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le député je ne vous parle pas
des boucliers je vous parle de la du
logement social à Aubervilliers dans
lequel d'après vous il y aurait du
chauffage en panne et je vous donne
rendez-vous dans ce logement social et
nous irons ensemble
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole s'il vous plaît la parole est à
Madame ma nièce car elle pour le groupe
horizon
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Économie
monsieur le ministre la forte
augmentation des coûts de l'énergie pèse
sur le budget des ménages des
collectivités mais également des
entreprises ce gouvernement et cette
majorité ont mis en place un bouclier
tarifaire qui protège les ménages plus
que par tout ailleurs en Europe un filet
de sécurité à destination des
collectivités qui sera renforcée et
recentrée l'année prochaine à
l'initiative du groupe horizon pour les
entreprises vous avez annoncé la mise en
place d'aide ciblées en fonction de leur
taille et des besoins partout dans nos
territoires les chefs d'entreprise
s'inquiète alors qu'ils doivent signer
leur contrat d'approvisionnement pour
l'année prochaine bien souvent les prix
sont multipliés par 3 4 ou 5 ce sont des
filières entières qui sont en danger et
des centaines de milliers d'entreprises
qui craignent de devoir freiner voire
stopper leur activité ou même de mettre
la clé sous la porte
dans ma circonscription la filière de la
pomme de terre est fortement impactée
par cette situation comme le son dans
chacun de nos territoires nos
agricultures nous agriculteurs artisans
chefs d'entreprise et industrie face à
ces situations critiques le groupe
horizon portera dans dans la loi
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables un amendement afin de
permettre aux collectivités et aux
entreprises de résilier à tout moment
leur contrats d'électricité ou de gaz
afin de bénéficier des tarifs de marché
plus favorables en fonction de la
conjoncture mais d'ici là les chefs
d'entreprise doivent signer leur contrat
d'approvisionnement en énergie pour
l'année prochaine pouvez-vous nous dire
très concrètement et avec pragmatisme
monsieur le ministre ce qu'ils doivent
faire
je vous remercie je vous remercie la
parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'Économie des Finances de
la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique
très concrètement madame la député de
votre question pour inviter tous les
chefs d'entreprise qu'ils soient
dirigeants d'une PME d'une entreprise de
taille intermédiaire d'une très grande
entreprise à déposer leurs factures
énergétique sur le site impôts gouv.fr
toutes celles qui ont une difficulté
pour payer leurs factures d'électricité
ou de gaz 2022 auront droit sous deux
conditions la première c'est que leurs
factures est augmentée de 50% et là
c'est le cas d'une très grande majorité
d'entreprises la deuxième c'est que
l'énergie représente 3% de leur chiffre
d'affaires c'est hélas aussi le cas
d'une grande partie des entreprises
elles auront droit à des aides qui
pourront aller entre maintenant et la
fin de l'année 2023 pour les PME jusqu'à
4 millions d'euros pour les grandes
entreprises industrielles jusqu'à 150
millions d'euros et je veux lever un
certain nombre parce que j'entends ces
inquiétudes j'étais hier avec la
ministre chargé des PME Olivia Grégoire
Montceau-les-Mines à la rencontre des
boulangers pour défendre les boulangers
les assurés de notre soutien un toutes
les entreprises sont concernées pas
uniquement les PME les GTI les grandes
entreprises les énergointensifs
également de nous veillerons à
l'application de la Charte ont signé les
énergéticiens toutes les entreprises ont
droit à plusieurs offres elles doivent
pouvoir comparer et prendre le meilleur
prix et 3 comme j'ai l'occasion de le
faire tout à l'heure avec le vice
chancelier allemand ministre de
l'Économie nous veillerons à l'équité de
concurrence entre l'Allemagne et la
France les entreprises françaises madame
la députés seront aussi bien protégés
que les entreprises allemandes je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre madame
Carrel merci Monsieur le Ministre cela
correspond à une réelle préoccupation de
nos entreprises et il y a une très forte
attente d'une communication ça n'éclaire
je vous remercie beaucoup merci la
parole est à Monsieur Eli kalifère pour
le groupe socialiste
oui merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse madame la ministre de
la transition énergétique madame la
ministre la géothermie est une énergie
d'avenir
la Banque européenne d'investissement et
la banque centrale allemande ont eu
conscience de cela en finançant la
centrale géothermique du Kenya pour plus
de 270 millions d'euros
dans sa politique de transition
énergétique présentée la semaine
dernière la France semble ignorer une de
ces richesses présente dans les régions
ultra périphériques la géothermie et
singulièrement en Guadeloupe avec la
centrale géothermique de Bouillante au
moment où nous parlons de transition
énergétique l'état de saisir avec
détermination cette source d'énergie
décarbonée pour renforcer notre mix
énergétique guadeloupéen aux Français
nous le savons la géothermie elle est
vertueuse elle est inébus diable pas de
carbone elle est en plus elle permettra
de fabriquer de l'hydrogène vers sans
émission de gaz à effet de serre
sortons la France et la Guadeloupe doit
dépendance énergétique des énergies
fossiles et du photovoltaïque chinois
madame la ministre pouvez-vous ramener
EDF qui vient de bénéficier de
subventions d'État dans le capital de la
SA géothermie de Bouillante c'est une
société
israélo-américaine qui gère madame
aminis consomme nous avec le Centre
d'excellence sur la géothermie que
devient implanter l'État en Guadeloupe
quelles sont vos engagements forts pour
le développement de la géothermie en
France et dans les outre-mer je vous
remercie
encore merci la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-François caraco ministre délégué
chargé des Outre-mer
la présidente mesdames messieurs les
députés monsieur le député qualifère la
géothermie est en effet une énergie
renouvelable prometteuse qui permet de
produire l'électricité la chaleur le
froid de manière décarbonée le
développement de la géothermie est donc
une véritable opportunité nous le savons
ensemble nous soutenons son
développement qui peut devenir non
seulement pour la Guadeloupe mais pour
tous les territoires d'outre-mer je
pense notamment à la Martinique un atout
dans leur trajectoire de décarbonation
et d'indépendance énergétique d'ailleurs
le ministère de la transition
énergétique va lancer très prochainement
ce plan
d'action géothermique sur la géothermie
profonde qui concerne tout
particulièrement la Guadeloupe ce plan
vise notamment améliorer la connaissance
du sous-sol pour limiter les risques
associés au projet de géothermie
profonde il s'agit aussi de sensibiliser
de faire monter en compétences tous les
acteurs locaux accompagnés les porteurs
de projets dans leur déploiement de
solutions sachez par ailleurs que nous
avons dès ce soir dès ce soir une
réunion interministérielle ou sera
abordée spécifiquement le cas de
Bouillante se pose en effet la question
de modifier le montant de l'ifère au
bénéfice notamment du conseil régional
de Guadeloupe c'est une question
importante vous pouvez compter sur moi
monsieur le député vous le savez pour
défendre le développement de la
géothermie et du renouvelable dans nos
outre-mer je connais tous les projets en
Guadeloupe c'est dans cette perspective
et dans le cadre de la PPE a modifié de
manière simplifiée à venir qu'ils seront
étudiés j'ai par ailleurs reçu récemment
les deux promoteurs potentiels sur les
deux projets nouveaux existant en Petite
Terre et les contacts sont déjà établis
avec EDF pour sortir un prix raisonnable
vous pouvez compter sur moi monsieur le
député qualifié
je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre
nous comptons surtout sur l'engagement
ferme et concret de l'État en faveur de
la géothermie avec des réponses précises
des engagements précis ça fait 40 ans
qu'on a commencé merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Steve
Chaillou pour le groupe PDF
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
mon intervention d'aujourd'hui face à la
représentation nationale sortira quelque
peu de l'orthodoxie habituel de cet
exercice bien connu des députés que nous
sommes et je vous prie par avance de
m'excuser elle s'inscrit en effet dans
les tiraillements du cœur et de l'âme
qui nous impose le deuil produit par
l'innommable tragédie dont souffre
actuellement l'ensemble de mon peuple
polynésien de souche de cœur ou
d'adoption le dimanche 6 novembre le
dernier à la suite des violons de pluie
qui se sont abattus en Polynésie le cœur
battant de notre finois fumeur tri par
une catastrophe qui a décimé des
innocents face aux déchaînement de la
nature nous devons rester humble car ce
jour-là la rivière veille tout auront
situé à papéno dans la commune de iti à
otera a décidé d'emporter d'engloutir
monsieur tewila Mike la petite teila my
Rota mihilani âgé de 8 ans le petit thé
Elite amatica âgé de 7 ans le petit
théouïa
toi épouse
enceinte de 8 mois et Madame Langlois
épousté Willa Marina seule et unique
survivante de ce drame l'inextricable
douleur suscité par cette tragédie a
conduit jusqu'à hier encore à la
mobilisation massive d'un angle sans
précédent de bénévoles venu aider les
secours dans la recherche de nos enfants
malheureusement en vain puisqu'ils n'ont
jamais été retrouvés je voudrais avec
émotion saluer le dévouement remarquable
dont on fait preuve les gendarmes les
pompiers les plongeurs les chasseurs les
bénévoles comme Madame Adèle Domingo et
tant d'autres ainsi que les élus
notamment le maire de la commune
Monsieur Henri flore et son conseil
municipal sans oublier le soutien sans
faille du haut-commissaire de la
République Monsieur elixpitz ainsi que
les services du gouvernement de la
Polynésie aujourd'hui je souhaite par
considération temple la douleur des
familles que pour celles de nos
compatriotes de l'ensemble de la
Polynésie exprimée humblement cette
émotion au sein de notre hémicy car il
n'y a mon sens point de plus grand
hommage que celui qui puisse être rendu
au cœur même de notre une démocratie
liberté égalité fraternité telle est la
devise de la République française je
voudrais terminer mon intervention
déclarant que je suis fier que les
polynésiens ont fait preuve pendant 10
jours d'une admirable fraternité je vous
remercie ma louloute
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie
la parole
monsieur le ministre
quand on est président
le 6 novembre à 16h30 la Polynésie a été
traversée par un épisode de pluie très
violente qui engendré une crue d'un
cours d'eau située dans une vallée
difficilement accessible de Tahiti un
véhicule avec 6 occupants deux femmes
dont une était enceinte un homme est
trois enfants qui tenterait de traverser
ce cours d'eau ont été emportés par les
flots aussitôt vous l'avez rappelé des
moyens considérables humains et
matériels de l'État et l'ensemble des
collectivités ont été déployées en
coordination avec la commune de IKEA la
police municipale les sapeurs-pompiers
les communes voisines la gendarmerie
l'armée les associations et les
bénévoles venus de toute la Polynésie en
fin d'après-midi une femme blessée a pu
être élittriée vers 19h et aujourd'hui
heureusement hors de danger un homme a
été retrouvé décédé aux alentours de 22h
depuis des recherches sont poursuivies
avec des moyens locaux appuyés par les
moyens de l'État sur la coordination du
maire le Haut Commissariat c'est que
tous les services de l'État sont restés
en appui de la commune mais après 15
jours de recherche les autorités locales
ont pris la décision de les arrêter sans
avoir retrouvé le corps des quatre
victimes restantes une femme enceinte et
3 enfants c'est toute la population
polynésienne vous l'avez souligné qui
vit cette tragédie je veux comme vous
ici saluer le courage et la négation de
tous les acteurs qui se sont mobilisés
pour essayer de retrouver ces malheureux
la solidarité face à la détresse a été
exemplaire et il faut nous en féliciter
toutes les composantes vous l'avez dit
de la République ont démontré leur
capacité à travailler ensemble mais il
nous faut aussi maintenant travailler
sur les questions du changement
climatique outre-mer c'est ce que nous
avons c'est ce que à quoi nous inviter
monsieur le Président de la République
avec Gérald Darmanin nous en avons parlé
nous avons commencé à travailler pour
établir un bilan global merci monsieur
le député de votre question
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Frédéric zinski
pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à Madame
la Ministre chargée des PME du Commerce
de l'Artisanat et du Tourisme à l'heure
de la sobriété énergétique nous devons
faire de la lutte contre tous les types
de gaspillage une priorité je me réjouis
que votre ministère est ainsi pris à
bras le corps le sujet extrêmement
important du gaspillage alimentaire
le décret paru au Journal officiel ce 18
novembre relatif aux modalités de
l'information des consommateurs sur le
caractère consommable des denrées
alimentaires en témoignent en effet
selon l'ADEME le sujet concerne près de
10 millions de tonnes de nourriture
consommables jetés chaque année en
France les nombreuses initiatives prises
depuis des années n'ont pu mettre fin à
ce gaspillage qui reste inacceptable car
une grande partie de ces aliments reste
consommables après l'expiration de la
DDM la date de durabilité minimale
il convient donc d'informer les
consommateurs sur la signification de
cette inscription et de rassurer sur les
enjeux de santé qu'ils peuvent soulever
et qui sont bien légitimes
la loi Haget votée par notre assemblée
en 2020 et soutenu par les députés du
groupe démocrate
prévoyaient des dispositions qui
allaient en ce sens et que votre décret
vient concrétiser
c'est normalement le cas de la mention
supplémentaire qui pourra désormais
accompagner la DDM
nous avons de ce point de vue un
important travail de pédagogie à faire
auprès des consommateurs notamment pour
lever les craintes en matière de risque
pour la santé madame la ministre
pouvez-vous nous dire ce que
concrètement se décrivent à changer et
quels efforts qu'on déployé le
gouvernement auprès des industriels d'un
côté et des consommateurs de l'autre
pour que cette mesure puisse contribuer
réellement à changer nos pratiques je
vous remercie je vous remercie la parole
est à Madame Olivia Grégoire ministre
délégué chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises du commerce de l'artisanat
et du tourisme merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Député Frédéric
gainski le gouvernement on le voit ne
relâche pas ses efforts pour protéger le
pouvoir d'achat et protéger et améliorer
en réalité aussi l'information faite aux
consommateur dans cette période de
d'inflation la mesure que vous évoquez
elle est très importante en réalité
puisqu'elle est très concrète
[Musique]
et nous avons donc décidé Bruno Le Maire
a signé le décret la semaine dernière
avec moi-même pour ajouter ce qu'on
appelle la DDM la date de durabilité
maximale en un mot vous trouverez
désormais sur les produits secs une
information plus explicite qui
expliquera que ce produit peut être
consommé après cette date et donc il y
aura moins de gaspillage et possibilité
de consommer sans aucun risque pour la
santé vous l'avez mentionné monsieur le
député pour les consommateurs aux
produits frais la date limite de
consommation aux produits secs la date
de durabilité maximale ce sont deux
informations que nous devions
consommateurs c'est désormais chose
faite je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Emmanuel Maquet
pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
de l'insertion monsieur le ministre plus
vos intentions sur la réforme des
retraites se précise plus elle révèle
des renoncements majeures le dernier en
date concerne les régimes spéciaux alors
que les français demandent la fin des
privilèges aujourd'hui injustifiés de
certains d'entre eux vous proposer à
clause du grand-père pour leur
suppression la situation financière des
retraites est urgente mais vous nous
proposez de légiférer pour dans 40 ans
c'est plutôt la clause du petit-fils
voir de l'arrière petit-fils monsieur le
ministre vous vous féliciter que le
climat des négociations avec les
syndicats soient bons mais quand on
connaît le conservatisme de certains
d'entre eux ce n'est pas un bon signe
pour votre réforme à l'heure où le
gouvernement nous parle de
l'acceptabilité il serait bon que
l'acceptabilité de cette réforme soit
celle des Français l'acceptabilité c'est
que chacun fasse un effort oui un effort
et pas uniquement le secteur privé au
contraire votre réforme qui étant
unifier les régimes oppose en réalité
les fonctionnaires les salariés du privé
laissent de côté les régimes spéciaux
monsieur le ministre la situation des
finances sociales et la sauvegarde de
notre modèle pour les Français exigent
du courage et de l'équité le courage
serait d'assurer une hausse de l'âge de
départ pour tous comme le groupe les
républicains le demandent depuis des
années comme tous nos grands pays
voisins et partenaires européens l'ont
fait et comme les Français sont prêts à
l'accepter travailler plus longtemps
alors que notre espérance de vie nous le
permet c'est non seulement préserver le
système de retraite mais aussi dégagé
les moyens de relever le minimum
retraite au-delà de 1100 euros comme
vous le prétendez vous avez abandonné
l'idée d'un système universel et avec
lui l'idée d'un système équitable
l'équité serait que pour des métiers
comparables les fonctionnaires les
salariés les bénéficiaires des régimes
spéciaux et des conditions de retraite
comparable ma question est donc simple
combien de milliards et de dettes
supplémentaires
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député maqué je vais essayer
de répondre simplement à une question et
si vous me permettrez je ferai aussi une
remarque sur le contexte politique dans
lequel nous allons examiner cette
réforme des retraites le président de la
République lorsqu'il était en campagne
pour l'élection présidentielle du
printemps dernier a pris un certain
d'engagement parmi les engagements il y
a la pérennité du système de retraite il
y a son amélioration il y a son retour à
l'équilibre il a ainsi fixé un cap ce
cap c'est de relever progressivement
l'âge de départ de 62 à 64 ans 2027 puis
de 64 ans à 65 ans en 2031 c'est ce cap
que nous tenons c'est ce cap que nous
tenons et c'est sur le mandat de
l'élection présidentielle que j'ai
ouvert sous l'autorité de la première
ministre un dernier cycle de
concertation avec les organisations
syndicales et les organisations
patronales quel est le double objectif
que nous poursuivons premier objectif
c'est d'améliorer améliorer un système
de retraite qui se caractérise par des
petites pensions qui sont beaucoup trop
basses améliorer un système de retraite
qui ne tient pas suffisamment compte de
la prévention de l'usure professionnelle
qui ne tient pas évidemment compte de la
pénibilité qui ne tient pas suffisamment
compte non plus de la précarité des
carrières de leur caractère parfois
haché et encore moins des inégalités
entre les femmes et les hommes améliorer
c'est faire plus d'équité et l'équité
c'est justement mener la réforme des
régimes spéciaux avec oui le choix de ce
qu'on appelle la clause de grand-père
parce que celles et ceux qui travaillent
aujourd'hui dans ces entreprises souvent
publics ont été recrutés ont signé un
contrat et que les contrats sont
assortis de droit et de devoir que nous
tenons de part et d'autre cela ne
signifie pas que la réforme ne
s'applique pas l'intégralité des
Français régime public régime privé
régime spéciaux seront aussi amenés à
travailler plus longtemps et à voir leur
âge légal de départ se décaler à du
proportion le deuxième objectif que nous
poursuivons c'est l'équilibre et
l'équilibre ça nécessite justement de
faire preuve de responsabilité et de
ramener un système qui affichera 12,5
milliards d'euros de déficit en 2027 à
l'équilibre c'est comme ça que nous
travaillons avec l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux mais si j'osais
monsieur le député on vous écoutant
finalement vous nous implorez d'avoir le
courage que vous n'avez jamais eu
[Musique]
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Alexis Isard
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente merci madame
la Présidente
mesdames les ministres mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre délégué chargé de l'Industrie
hier lundi 21 novembre débuté la 11e
Semaine de l'Industrie
occlusion de valoriser le secteur et ses
acteurs en proposant des événements
pédagogiques et de découverte des
métiers chaque année ce grand
rendez-vous contribue à renforcer
l'attractivité de l'industrie auprès des
jeunes à promouvoir la mixité des
métiers et la place des femmes dans les
différentes filières
l'industrie en France depuis 5 ans c'est
plus d'emplois plus d'attractivité plus
d'investissements depuis 2017 le secteur
industriel a recommencé à créer des
emplois ce n'était pas arrivé depuis 10
ans
ces résultats ne sont pas le fruit du
hasard mais d'une politique industrielle
conséquente avec des réformes de
structures et une baisse inédite de la
fiscalité porté par cette majorité
depuis 5 ans
ce mouvement doit se poursuivre nous
avons la volonté politique de le faire
et des moyens via France 2030 il faut
désormais donner envie d'industrie à
toutes et tous 250 000 postes sont à
pourvoir d'ici 2025
cependant aujourd'hui encore l'industrie
souffre de contre-vérité elle serait
polluante difficile à la chaîne la
réalité est tout autre et vous pouvez
vécu le constater monsieur le ministre
quand vous êtes venus chez moi en
Essonne soutenir l'industrie et
valoriser son excellence la diversité de
ses profils et sa féminisation
nous devons accompagner les jeunes pour
rendre attractif ce secteur élargir le
vivier de recrutement renforcer la
diversification de ses talents anticiper
les besoins à horizon 2030 ainsi ma
question est simple quelles actions
comptez-vous mettre en œuvre pour
poursuivre le mouvement de
réindustrialisation engagée sur notre
territoire à l'occasion de cette onzième
édition de la Semaine de l'Industrie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Roland Lescure ministre délégué
chargé de l'Industrie
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
parler très fort
ce micro est made in France madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Alexis j'ai
une conviction
faire de la France
une économie verte et souveraine passera
par l'industrie nous avons un cap c'est
France nations vertes nous avons des
moyens France 2030 qui un an après avoir
été annoncé par le président de la
République et lancer à l'Élysée fait
déjà l'objet de près de 10 milliards
d'euros d'engagement sur les 54
milliards d'euros prévus et pourquoi
faire tout simplement avec un objectif
très clair poursuivre et accélérer ce
que nous avons fait vous l'avez dit
depuis 5 ans
réindustrialiser la France avec ambition
et un cap très clair décarboné
d'industrie traditionnelle et développer
l'industrie de la décarbonation
et France et la Semaine de l'Industrie
pardon c'est une semaine qui doit nous
permettre de donner envie aux jeunes et
aux moins jeunes aux hommes et aux
femmes de rejoindre les beaux métiers de
l'industrie ce sont 46 000 événements
qui sont présents dans tous les
territoires et donc j'engage les députés
de tous les bancs à se rendre dans les
industries à rencontrer les industriels
à y rencontrer les jeunes hommes les
jeunes filles qui souhaitent rejoindre
l'industrie j'étais hier avec la
ministre de l'Égalité famome à Créteil
nous avons rencontré des jeunes filles
de lycées qui souhaitent rejoindre
l'industrie grâce à des zones
d'ingénieurs qui les en ont convaincus
jeudi à Bercy nous ouvrons Bercy à
l'industrie Bercy fait son industrie et
j'aurai l'occasion de rejoindre le
ministre de l'éducation nationale avec
mille jeunes lycéens pour leur présenter
les métiers de l'industrie et les
convaincre que l'industrie c'est
l'avenir nous terminerons cette belle
journée par un concours d'éloquence nous
ferons mesdames et messieurs les députés
le procès de l'industrie que j'espère
l'industrie gagnera avec brio
illustrer c'est l'avenir de la France
c'est l'avenir des jeunes c'est l'avenir
de la planète rejoignez l'industrie
c'est les Bénin industrie belle semaine
à toutes et à tous
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric
cabrolier pour le rassemblement national
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires en août
2021 la loi climat est résilience a été
votée sans concertation avec les élus
locaux ce qui a pour conséquence de les
rendre aujourd'hui très inquiets cette
loi dite zéro artificialisation nette et
destinée à limiter les surfaces
constructives
dorénavant les documents d'urbanisme
devront respecter la règle suivante
jusqu'en 2030 seront autorisés à la
construction 50% des superficie
artificialisées durant les 10 dernières
années de plus sont inclus dans ce
calcul des grands projets nationaux sur
lesquels les élus locaux n'ont aucune
prise
or au cours des 10 dernières années à
l'échelle nationale le rythme
d'artificialisation se situe au dessus
autour de 28400 hectares par an mais les
taux d'artificialisation varient de 4 à
20% selon les régions et ces différences
sont encore plus marquées entre les
intercommunalités vous comprenez
aisément que cette règle de réduction de
moitié appliquée uniformément l'ensemble
du territoire français est injuste
certains territoires ont été peu
artificialisés sur les 10 dernières
années et l'application stricte de cette
loi qu'on dirait conduirait à pénaliser
le comportement vertueux de certaines
collectivités depuis la crise sanitaire
le monde rural est plébiscité il faut
pouvoir accueillir dans les meilleures
conditions ceux qui souhaitent venir
s'installer en campagne l'application de
cette loi aura l'effet inverse souhaité
les campagnes vont continuer de se
dépeupler au détriment des grandes
métropoles qui ne sont guère des
parangons de vertus en matière
environnementale aussi Monsieur le
ministre les efforts de certains
doivent-ils contribuer à ce que les
mauvais élèves du passé consomment dans
les 10 prochaines années plus de terrain
que ceux qui ont été vertueux par le
passé tout en pénalisant les territoires
ruraux je vous remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les députés pour une question
je pense que je vais avoir l'occasion de
vous apporter des éléments de réponse
qui vont vous convenir mais d'un mot
d'abord pourquoi est-ce que ce texte
existe toutes les heures
nous consommons nos artificialisons dans
ce pays l'équivalent de 5 terrains de
football depuis que nous avons commencé
ces séances de questions gouvernement
c'est l'équivalent de 8 terrains de
football qui ont été artificialisés je
comprends que pour certains ce ne soit
pas grave mais si vous voulez qu'on
préserve notre agriculture qu'on
préserve nos sols qu'on garde une
capacité de captation du carbone lutter
contre cet artificialisation est une
nécessité la loi à laquelle vous faites
référence elle a été votée par
l'Assemblée et le Sénat à l'issue d'une
commission mixte paritaire et elle a
fini par réunir tout le monde y compris
sur cet objectif en revanche le sujet ce
sont ces modalités d'application les
difficultés liées au décret de la fin du
mois d'avril m'ont conduit à les
suspendre et à les réécrire à la fois
avec les associations des lieux et les
agences d'urbanisme et le point que vous
soulignez juste il ne faut pas que le
zéro artificialisation se soit on prend
ce que vous avez fait par le passé on le
divise par deux de manière automatique
ça pas comme ça que la loi a été votée
la loi elle prévoit une
territorialisation par région de manière
à faire en sorte qu'on puisse au
contraire tenir compte sur des bassins
de territoires de ces différences de
dynamiques et de vertus par rapport au
passé mais aussi des différences de
progression de population à la minute où
on se parle avec l'Association des
maires de France et David Lisnard avec
l'Association des régions de France nous
sommes en train y compris avec la
majorité sénatoriale de proposer des
évolutions de ce texte qui seront dans
les tous prochains jours présentés
d'assouplissement à la fois sur les
grands projets nationaux je pense à
scène Nord-Europe je pense au LGV
d'Occitanie mais pas seulement pour
faire en sorte qu'effectivement on
n'applique pas une loiveugle mais qu'on
tienne un objectif de lutte contre
l'artificialisation que nous ne pouvons
pas différer si nous voulons lutter
contre les règlements climatique je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Madame Frédéric meunier pour le
complet républicain
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
messieurs les ministres nos communes
rurales s'inquiètent elles expriment
leur profonde préoccupations concernant
les conséquences de la crise économique
et financière sur leurs dépenses et
leurs recettes sur leur capacité à
investir et sur le maintien d'une offre
de service de proximité adapté aux
besoins de la population elles doivent
faire face à une situation sans
précédent l'augmentation de l'énergie
des produits alimentaires et des
matériaux connaissent une hausse
spectaculaire ce qui compromet gravement
l'équilibre des budgets de
fonctionnement et les capacités
d'investissement l'augmentation de 3,5%
du point d'indice des agents
territoriaux non compensés par l'État et
la suppression de la tvae ces mesures de
restriction financières de nos communes
ne se justifient pas les collectivités
locales votent leur budget en équilibre
et les soldes qu'elles dégagent
contribuent au contraire à limiter le
déficit public vous les sanctionnez
alors qu'elles ne le mérite pas et 15
milliards d'euros de restriction de
dépenses imposées aux collectivités
locales d'ici 2027 sont en réalité des
restrictions imposées à la population
car c'est autant de moins pour financer
l'offre de services l'Association des
maires de France a fait des propositions
pour indexer la DGF sur l'inflation en
2023 pour moduler la suppression de la
CVAE pour créer un bouclier énergétique
d'urgence plafonnant le prix des chats
d'achat de l'électricité pour toutes les
collectivités locales aussi au moment où
se déroule à Paris le Congrès des mers
allez-vous entendre la voix des élus
locaux et soutenir les positions de
l'Association des maires de France je
vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe bech je suis
ministre la transition écologique et des
collectivités de la cohésion des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée meunier vous évoquez deux
sujets les communes rurales et toutes
les communes dans leur entier je saisis
votre question pour vous dire que
vendredi avec Dominique Faure nous
réunirons le Parlement rural à la
demande de ce qu'il compose de
l'Association des Maires Ruraux de
France pour évoquer un certain nombre de
propositions concrètes je pense devenir
des zones de revitalisation rurales je
pense aux besoins d'accompagnement
spécifique qui existe pour ces
territoires et nous avons prévu une
demi-journée spécifique d'échanges avec
ces territoires dont nous savons à la
fois l'attractivité les inquiétudes
parfois compte tenu du poids de
certaines intercommunalités et j'en
profite pour le dire
du dernier rapport de la Cour des
comptes qui lance dans l'atmosphère une
suggestion qui n'est souhaitée par
personne qui serait le transfert de la
DGF des communes vers les
intercommunalités nous ne soutenons pas
la perspective de la perte de DGF par
les communes au profit des
intercommunalités et je profite de ce
moment pour le dire de manière
extrêmement claire ensuite vous évoquez
la situation plus large et effectivement
la nature du soutien que nous apportons
à ces communes hier soir avec le bureau
exécutif de l'Association des Maires ce
matin au salon dans les jours qui
viennent nous poursuivons une discussion
la DGF c'est la première fois depuis 13
ans qu'elle augmente on nous demande de
faire davantage mais ces 320 millions
contre 0 ces dernières années et près de
12 milliards de pertes pendant le
quinquennat de François Hollande sur le
filet de sécurité il y a 1,5 milliards
d'euros sur lequel la co-construction
législative avec la majorité sénatoriale
se poursuit pour trouver le dispositif
qui soit le plus ajusté et nous
confiance au sénateur pour faire évoluer
le dispositif dans le cadre d'un soutien
réel c'est le sens des discussions que
nous avons enfin je tiens malgré tout à
vous rappeler que 28 000 communes de ce
pays sont préservées par le bouclier
tarifaire notamment les communes rurales
dont vous avez parlé qui bénéficient de
ce soutien et d'un plafond total à
hauteur de 15%. je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre madame meunier oui
monsieur le ministre j'écoute avec
beaucoup d'intérêts ce que vous dites je
vous rappelle que les communes sont les
socles les communes sont le socle de
notre démocratie et ne commettez pas
l'erreur du passé tout à l'heure on
parlait du passé et je pense que vous
nous remettez souvent le passé en pleine
figure Laya la loi nôtre de 2014 la loi
notre a été un véritable échec alors
vous parlez du Parlement rural c'est une
nouveauté un parlement de plus quand
elle quand elle a elle a la dotation
générale la DGF elle a été financière
merci merci la parole est à Madame
Christine Arrighi pour le groupe
écologiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adressait donc à Madame borne mais qui
n'est pas là et donc j'imagine que
d'autres pourront répondre à sa place
larist tourne gouvernementale la
ristourne gouvernementale sur le
carburant coûtera plus de 8 milliards
d'euros au finances publiques nous vous
avons déjà proposé proposons à nouveau
l'adoption d'une mesure beaucoup plus
efficace et peu coûteuse du tout
justement le passage à 110 km sur
l'autoroute rouler à 110 km au lieu de
130 permet de réduire de 25% le
carburant consommé de 20% nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre c'est donc une
mesure de sobriété une mesure de
préservation du pouvoir d'achat une
manière de réduire notre dépendance aux
énergies fossiles d'améliorer la balance
des paiements et enfin c'est primordial
de préserver les vies humaines
aujourd'hui 63% des Français y sont
favorables alors madame borne s'est
exprimée la semaine dernière et a
exprimer son désaccord pour une telle
mesure car je cite
ne peut pas fonctionner à court
d'interdiction alors je vous fais ici la
proposition d'inscrire une telle mesure
dans une perspective plus large
d'acceptation sociale en faveur de
l'écologie et du pouvoir d'achat cette
perspective c'est de mettre fin à la
privatisation des autoroutes et en
attendant de négocier la baisse des
tarifs aux CPH qui sont excessivement
élevés et qui pèsent sur le pouvoir
d'achat des Françaises et des Français
car je cite si on n'est pas attentif à
embarquer tout le monde à un moment
donné on avance pas alors que
pensez-vous d'une telle proposition de
co-construction madame borne ou d'autres
qui pourront y répondre
je vous remercie mes chers collègues la
parole est à monsieur Clément bonne
ministre délégué chargé des transports
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Christine erghi vous excuserez sans
doute l'absence de la première ministre
pour répondre à cette question j'espère
que la réponse vous éclairera néanmoins
nous avons une convergence la nécessité
de changer les comportements pour la
transition écologique nous avons une
forte divergence c'est que vous voulez
tout faire reposer sur la contrainte sur
une règle unique et sur l'obligation
systématique ça n'est pas notre approche
et je crois que ce n'est pas l'approche
la plus efficace pour réussir la
transition écologique par ailleurs
pardonnez-moi et nous avons l'occasion
d'en parler à plusieurs reprises je note
un certain nombre de contradiction je
crois que la privatisation des
autoroutes n'a pas grand chose à voir
dans cette histoire mais baisser les
péages et vouloir contraindre le recours
à la voiture c'est un peu contradictoire
je crois que vous étiez au contraire
pour essayer de rendre plus coûteuse
l'usage de la voiture et donc je le
comprends pas bien le raisonnement
d'ensemble que vous essayez de déployer
en revanche je vais être très clair sur
les 110 km/h vous avez raison sur un
point c'est que les 110 km/h c'est
l'occasion de le rendre dire ici c'est
bon pour le climat et c'est bon pour le
pouvoir d'achat parce que ça permet de
faire jusqu'à 20% d'économie de
carburant et 20% d'économie d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre le rendre
obligatoire systématique je pense que ce
serait pas une bonne idée parce qu'il y
a des usages très différents allez une
fois par an prendre l'autoroute pour les
vacances ce n'est pas comme l'utiliser
tous les jours pour se rendre au travail
l'État comme employeur en revanche
montre exemplaire montre une
recommandation demande à ses agents dans
l'usage des voitures de service de
réduire la vitesse sur autoroute faisons
confiance à la responsabilité faisons
confiance aux changements de
comportement ne soyons pas
systématiquement dans une contrainte et
une règle qui rendront la transition
écologique je le crois moins efficace et
moins durable
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame ariguet donc monsieur bonne je
suppose qu'en 1974 vous auriez voté
contre la réduction de la limitation de
vitesse de 140 à 130 sur les autoroutes
puisque une interdiction avait été déjà
prononcé en ce sens à cette époque là
par ailleurs je signale que aujourd'hui
les dividendes des autoroutes c'est 40
milliards d'euros dont 32 pour Vinci
Eiffage tandis que la privatisation 2006
n'a rapporté que 14 milliards donc il y
a des choses
la parole est à Madame Nicole du
bréchira pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Olivier dussope
monsieur le ministre nous avons adopté
la semaine dernière le projet de loi
portant en mesure d'urgence relative aux
fonctionnements du marché du travail en
vue du plein emploi avec ce texte
l'objectif est d'aller vers le plein
d'emploi objectif crédible atteignable
avec un taux de chômage de 7,4% au
deuxième trimestre 2022 et dans ma
propre circonscription de 4,3% taux les
plus bas depuis 15 ans avec notamment le
recul du chômage des jeunes des seniors
et des personnes handicapées la première
réforme en 2019 n'avait plus produire
ses effets du fait de la crise sanitaire
réforme qui visait à diminuer les
embauches multiples en contre-atts en
2021 avec une reprise économique rapide
et le souhait de salarié de changer
d'orientation et de se reconvertir la
France observe des métiers en tension et
des difficultés de recrutement dans de
multiples secteurs d'activités en 2022
Emmanuel Macron proposait une
modification du système d'assurance
chômage plus quand trop d'emploi sont
non pourvu plus généreuses quand le
chômage est élevé un sondage publié en
août 2022 montrait que 60% des Français
se disent favorables au changement
envisagés dans le cadre de cette réforme
45% d'entre eux sites comme première
explication au chômage un système
d'indemnisation trop généreux qui
n'incite pas au retour à l'emploi c'est
dans ce contexte que le gouvernement a
proposé un système de
contracyclicité en lien avec la
conjoncture pour que les règles
d'indemnisation soient plus incitatives
lorsque la situation économique est
bonne plus protectrice lorsqu'elle se
dégrade la déclinaison de cette loi
était travaillée en concertation avec
les partenaires sociaux vous avez pu
définir un plan d'action pouvez-vous
nous en donner le contenu les modalités
et l'échéancier d'autre part avez-vous
envisagé des mesures spécifiques pour
les personnes les plus éloignées de
l'emploi nécessitant un accompagnement
plus long et adapté je vous remercie la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier du socle
le ministre du Travail du plein emploi
et de l'insertion dans la précédente
madame la députée du bréshira vous
l'avez dit hier et à la suite de
l'adoption Parlement de la loi portant
première mesure sur le marché du travail
j'ai présenté aux partenaires sociaux
les règles de modulation de des règles
de modulation de l'indemnisation de
l'assurance chômage pour tenir compte de
la conjoncture économique de l'état du
marché du travail et ceux fidèlement
l'engagement pris par le Président de la
République notre objectif est clair
c'est avoir un système plus incitatif
quand les choses ont bien sur le marché
de l'emploi c'est le cas aujourd'hui
d'avoir un système plus protecteur quand
les choses vont mal et si ce que nous
avons adopté avec vous permet de
d'appliquer cette règle tout au long de
l'année 2023 il faudra ensuite que les
partenaires sociaux reprennent leurs
compétences dans le cadre du paritarisme
et prolonge cet élan dans le cadre d'un
documentation que nous leur donnerons
les premiers résultats sont là en termes
d'emploi ils ne sont malheureusement pas
suffisants puisque même si le taux de
chômage a baissé de 9,5 à 7,3% nous
avons encore beaucoup de chômage mais
nous avons aussi beaucoup de tension de
recrutement ça doit nous inviter à
mobiliser tous les leviers c'est leviers
autour de l'assurance chômage mais pas
seulement des leviers en matière
d'insertion par l'activité économique le
projet de loi de finance que vous à
examiner en deuxième lecture prévoit
plus d'un milliard 300 millions d'euros
pour financer l'insertion par l'activité
économique c'est 400 millions d'euros de
plus qu'en 2018 nous augmentons aussi
les crédits pour ce qui concerne les
entreprises adaptées ainsi que les ESAT
afin de faciliter l'accès à l'emploi des
personnes en situation de handicap vous
accompagnons aussi les plus jeunes pour
faire en sorte que par le contrat
d'engagement jeunesse il puisse
retrouver la voie d'une formation
qualifiante ou de l'emploi puis nous
accompagnons tout simplement les
demandeurs d'emploi et par exemple alors
que en moyenne 600 000 demandeurs
d'emploi et avaient accès à une
formation pendant cette période
d'indemnisation entre octobre 2021 et
octobre 2022 ce sont un million 600000
demandeurs d'emploi que nous avons formé
nous allons continuer à le faire avec
une garantie une certitude c'est que nul
n'est-il d'employable et que le chemin
du plan emploi est devant nous nous
allons continuer à le faire en donnant
des moyens et nous allons continuer à le
faire en veillant est-ce que tout le
monde puisse être emmené accompagné et
qu'on puisse offrir un accompagnement
adapté à chacun c'est notamment le cas
de tous les bénéficiaires minima sociaux
que nous voulons accompagner plus
fortement vers l'emploi et un emploi de
qualité
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Pierre Morel à
l'huissier pour le groupe Lyot merci
Madame présidente mes chers collègues
messieurs les ministres je ne sais à
quel ministre il faut s'adresser
concernant la prédation du loup celui de
l'agriculture ou sur l'environnement
j'ai fêté interroger le gouvernement ce
matin lors des questions orales sans
divers ni une mise agricultures ni le
Miss environnement n'était présent c'est
à mon signe c'est à mon sens un signe
vous avez ainsi laissé le ministre la
ville m'apportait des réponses sur le
loup dans nos territoires ruraux
c'est-à-dire une fin de non-recevoir sur
la révision de la conventionnelle et la
directive communautaire
en contradiction totale est-ce que ce
que j'ai entendu ce matin le ministre
agriculture lors du conseil des
ministres européens du 26 septembre
avait déclaré il y a un risque de
disparition d'activités agricoles je
soutiens l'intérêt de réexéminer la
directive à le 2 août Sénat le même
ministre était engagé à faire évoluer le
statut du loup sa population étant
désormais hors de danger d'extinction au
niveau européen et aujourd'hui vous
faites marche arrière quelle explication
tangible pouvez-vous donner au monde de
l'élevage pourquoi ne pas soutenir la
démarche de la Suisse sur la Convention
de Berne au delà combien d'argent public
est consommé au titre des plans loups
successifs en termes de mesure de
protection d'achat de clôture d'achat de
Patou de rumination des bergers de
brigadeslots et enfin d'indemnisation
des prédateurs tout cela coûte beaucoup
d'argent public et vous le savez
pourquoi les éleveurs ne sont-ils
indivisés qu'à 80% et nous à 100%.
pourquoi le budget est-il pris sur le
ministère de l'Agriculture et non sur le
mystère de l'environnement pourquoi
continuer à financer
les associations proloux avec de
l'argent public associations qui
contestent tous les arrêtés
préfectorales de tir
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Bérengère Couillard secrétaire d'État
chargé de l'écologie
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Morel à l'huissier sachez que le
gouvernement est mobilisé face à la
détresse des éleveurs français il faut
préserver les élevages dont le nombre ne
cesse de baisser depuis 20 ans notre
méthode de suivi de la population de
loups est reconnue comme l'une des plus
efficaces d'Europe elle sera maintenue
au moins jusqu'au terme du plan national
d'action soit fin 2023 il est essentiel
que la confiance soit rétablie entre
tous les acteurs concernés agent de
l'ofb membre du réseau de suivi éleveur
chasseur élus tous doivent être
impliqués en souhaitant le déclassement
du Loup vous appelez à davantage
d'efficacité dans les tirs nécessaires à
la protection des élevages le nombre de
loups dont la destruction peut être
autorisée chaque année et fixé à 19% de
la population estimée pour
202274 sont autorisés car l'estimation
de la population a été revue à la hausse
pour une meilleure efficacité le
gouvernement a décidé de moderniser le
matériel utilisé par les louvetiers à
hauteur de 400 000 euros vous appelez au
déclassement du loup qui est une espèce
strictement protégée au niveau national
européen et également international avec
la Convention de Berne un déclassement
ne peut être la solution à court terme
car il est peu vraisemblable il faudrait
que l'espèce soit parfaitement restaurée
et que la décision de déclassement soit
prise à l'unanimité des pays de plus
dans l'hypothèse ou le loup se
trouverait se retrouverait déclassé il
ferait l'objet d'une gestion de type
cinégénique avec la définition de quota
et de modalités de prélèvement or il
n'est pas démontré qu'un tel changement
présenterait des résultats en termes de
réduction des dommages la priorité du
gouvernement elle est de faciliter les
mesures de protection notamment les tirs
plus proches des élevages et d'améliorer
aussi les modalités d'accompagnement des
agriculteurs c'est indispensable
notamment dans les territoires tels que
la Lozère ou le loup commet ces
premières prédations nous sommes avec
Christophe Béchu Marc féno
particulièrement mobilisé je vous
remercie monsieur Morel à l'huissier
11000 au vin qui sont morts
237 bovins et on continue à ne pas
regarder la réalité venez sur le terrain
venez voir les éleveurs écoutez-les
venez voir des personnes de 55 ans qui
pleurent avec des brebis qui sont en
train d'agoniser voilà la réalité
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame
Nadège à beaumont-goli pour le groupe la
France insoumise
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai même
mon métier mais j'ai arrêté il ne m'est
pas mettez pas de vivre dignement
témoignage d'Emmanuel dans Ouest-France
elle est aesh accompagnement des lèvres
en situation de handicap cette année
encore de nombreux enfants ne peuvent
bénéficier de l'accompagnement auquel
ils ont droit certains sont des
scolarisés alors pourquoi parce que le
gouvernement ne fait rien aussi peu pour
les aesh à chaque rentrée vous abordez
benoîtement ce phénomène d'ampleur à
chaque rentrée il manque des aesh les
aesh c'est le cumul des précarités au
travail très majoritairement des femmes
payées en moyenne 800 euros par mois des
déplacements entre plusieurs
établissements peu de formation et pas
d'intégration à la communauté éducative
le métier n'est pas attractif le métier
n'est pas reconnu la situation est telle
que le marché des aesh privé est en
plein essor ceci détruit l'école
républicaine et l'égalité des droits
je défends une proposition de loi qui
revendique sa création d'un statut de
fonctionnaire pour les aesh pour une
meilleure rémunération avec 24 heures de
travail payer temps plein qui prennent
en compte les heures de travail
invisibles pour des formations tout au
long de la carrière pour un parcours
professionnel avec mobilité je leur ai
affirme la création d'un accord de
fonctionnaires et justifier parce que
c'est une mission nécessaire pérenne
exigeant des compétences spécifiques
parce que l'État doit reconnaître leur
caractère essentiel pour une école
inclusive et universelle pourtant en
commission la meilleure était
présidentielle a choisi de tourner le
dos aux austh à leur refusé le statut le
gouvernement terrible la précarité en
proposant un hypothétique CDI au bout de
trois ans bien au-delà de la moyenne
d'ancienneté dans la profession pire
vous démontez d'étendre leur mission
comme si ce n'était pas assez le message
envoyé est clair restez à votre place
monsieur le ministre quand cessez-vous
devant les aesh comme des femmes à tout
faire quand comptez-vous créer un corps
de fonctionnaires pour les austh c'est
aussi une revendication
des morts féministes
je vous remercie
la parole est un monsieur papenza est
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
à beaumont-goli la proposition que vous
faites de création d'un corps de
fonctionnaires aesh à le goût du progrès
peut-être on a l'apparence mais elle
n'en a pas la réalité et ce pour deux
raisons
premièrement vous voulez créer un corps
de fonctionnaire et dans votre idée il
s'agirait il s'agirait d'un corps de
fonctionnaires de catégories B hors pour
cela il faut le bac à releur seul 20%
des aesh ont actuellement le
baccalauréat par conséquent votre
proposition aurait pour effet d'exclure
80% des aesh actuels de votre nouveau
corps de fonctionnaire beau progrès
belle avancée merci pour eux et merci
pour elle deuxième deuxième élément
pour entrer dans la fonction publique
aux dernières nouvelles il faut avoir la
citoyenneté française hors des aesh il y
a des ash qui n'ont pas la nationalité
française par conséquent vous les
excluez beau progrès belle avancées je
vous remercie pour eux nous ce que nous
faisons concrètement c'est d'ailleurs
avec le travail de ces groupes nous
augmentons les députés nous augmentons
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
augmentons les aesh de 10% l'année
prochaine ils ont accès aux primes
réplus nous créons 4000 postes
supplémentaires et nous favorisons la
civilisation au bout de trois années
avec deux surcroît des formations qui
viennent appuyer cela voilà ce que nous
réalisons concrètement plutôt que des
fausses promesses qui n'aboutissent en
fait qu'à exclure une partie des
personnels aesh du fameux corps de
fonctionnaires dont vous rêvez on est
bien avancé grâce à votre proposition
merci
Monsieur le Ministre madame abo manguili
il vous reste 5 secondes
allez-y toute les obstacles que vous
aimez peuvent être levés dans ce public
monsieur le ministre vous le savez vous
le connaissez pas la fonction publique
ni service public je vous remercie la
séance de questions au Gouvernement est
terminée la séance c'est suspendue pour
une durée de 15 minutes et nous
reprendrons sur le vote solennel